foreign
foreign
okay
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
okay
thank you
foreign
foreign
I'm worried about my espresso machine
I'm not
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my lathe
um
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
the lawyers are lawyers the lawyers are
lawyers get rid of the machine I've
tried call getting rid of the machines
just pillows who did this attack who did
this Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said he said
[Music]
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through on
the way to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that is said no you're not getting my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
wrong he said no we're not gonna arrest
you I sure you can do anything you have
yet and you can do it you can just
hear it from get rid of the machine I've
tried about getting rid of the machine
I'm worried about my pillow no no that's
the worst thing for you because your
cervical nerves in your neck I will send
you some pillows I'm worried about my
legs
Okay Melt them down and turn them into
prison bars
all right thanks Mike Take Care thank
you
thank
you
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
[Music]
what on Earth is going on with Trump and
toilets
[Music]
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms Arya
looking for a place to watch some news
where people don't yell while wearing
suits I know of a guy who fits that bill
of progressive with political will but
David pectin shall see your political
knowledge
who's the current president of the
United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question
sign up foreign
[Music]
have been growing with one huge pepper
all summer it's time to pluck it
foreign
[Music]
boxes are just so bad no more drop boxes
Dickinson hologic and cephe cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
[Music]
their voice droved truth essential he
voted against Kate's law and he voted
for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the cut some of the world's
greatest cricket players from suchin
tendulkeron
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive
what said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantry Ben badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
but it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
law and auto look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables and about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
Recycling and signing and the great
General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he we appreciate it very
much Tim Apple when they gaze upon your
semites your seminites towering Sequoias
they deliver they swept and swept in you
know that sweeping it was Swift and it
was sweeping like the nobody's ever seen
anything happen units of plasma for
plasma donate plasma in the failing New
York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading woman's business the teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children well enough
correct of himself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you've heard them and you know them well
all right welcome everybody what a day
what a day what a day we are here and
moments away potentially from the start
of the 2024 presidential election Donald
Trump originally reported as planning
planning to announce his candidacy next
Monday but it is now apparent to some
that it will be tonight now where did I
get that
well I got it from Trump himself I mean
don't take my word for it listen to this
have to do it again but stay tuned
this is from yesterday's rally
okay let me skip ahead for you
it's pretty good thank you
stay tuned to tomorrow night in the
great state of Ohio there it is and that
is tonight
that is tonight and there are now
multiple reports Trump wants to announce
he is running for president ASAP could
come as early as Monday
that is uh quite a claim quite a claim
and we will be standing by for it
everywhere that you can imagine now
let's just get our imagery completely
appropriate for everybody only the best
for my audience let's tweak
and we will get this it's just going to
be a perfect thing for you
uh there we go
and there we go and we'll just dump it
here
and then stretch and Pull and the entire
thing there we go
um Trump expected in 22 minutes 22
minutes all right everybody very very
important stuff Eric says where do we
find a link to that new super cut before
the stream of trumpisms I laughed out
loud quite a few times we're expanding
it once we have a final version we'll
make it available so if you have
specific Trump glitches that we didn't
include please email info
davidpackman.com and let let me know
ideally with a link and then we'll add
the additional Trump glitches Sue chin
tendulker
Vivek
and all of those okay so uh very very
exciting stuff now I I you know it's
great to see everybody
and it's all very important and Trump
May announce and tomorrow is the
election and we're going to be live but
I do want to remind everybody you'd
better damn well be voting tomorrow okay
whether it's half cefahide or for
whatever different reason these are the
most important midterm elections I have
ever covered we are now at an inflection
point tomorrow between 7 and 8 Eastern
we'll start okay
we are in an inflection point
are we as a country saying okay
the four years of trump that was bad we
brought in Joe Biden and now we're going
to reject these anti-democracy
authoritarian clueless some of them are
mentally ill lunatics we're going to
reject it and we're going to go back to
sanity that's one possible outcome
the other possible outcome is we had the
four years of trump
we thought we were getting out of it
when Biden won
and now it's doubling and tripling down
and you know as Thomas Homer Dixon said
could the U.S become a right-wing
dictatorship by 2030. I believe that in
10 20 40 years
this midterm
and the 2024 election which depends on
this midterm will be a critical
inflection point in American history
that's my prediction I don't make too
many predictions because quite frankly
we're humans are pretty bad at making
predictions
but that is my prediction now
it's not looking great in many ways
there is an 84 percent chance
that Republicans take
the House of Representatives okay
and there is now a 58 chance that
Republicans win the Senate now this is
the 538 average I'm going to tell
everybody right now
I don't believe that this polling is
accurate
what is the actual polling is a
different question which is irrelevant
at this point in time
and what I mean by that is
I have one vote you have one vote
everybody has one vote
you either live in Pennsylvania or you
don't if you live in Pennsylvania you
get to vote mastriano versus Shapiro uh
Oz versus fetterman okay
there are all sorts of different claims
being made that the polls are wildly
inaccurate this year
fine
then we'll find out tomorrow night okay
it doesn't make a difference we have a
vote
a lot of these races are extraordinarily
close
and we will we will know the answers
tomorrow night now let me speak again
to the people
who keep emailing emailing me and say
David I feel like it's pointless these
elections never come down to one vote
now of course that's true
but this is the the important thing
there's a whole bunch of people out
there who go I just vote for all the
Democrats on the ballot there's a whole
bunch of people out there who just say I
just vote for every Republican on the
ballot whatever
and then there's a whole bunch of people
out there who go I don't know that I'm
going to vote because one vote never
made a difference
you're not alone in saying that
think of yourself as part of a group of
Voters all of us who think to ourselves
should I bother
it never comes down to one vote
if all of us who have that thought stay
home
they win
if all of us who say it never comes down
just to my vote say wait
but together we can make a difference if
we all go and vote then we win so when
that thought occurs to you and I know it
occurs to many well my one my one vote
won't make a difference you're not the
only one thinking that
your your vote is just as important as
everyone else's who thinks that
and if you all stay home then we lose
sorry I just froze there because it was
so profound what I just said okay I've
recovered thank you
um in all seriousness folks this is very
important all right let's get to some
super chats that are coming in here did
I see Ted Cruz was booed at the Houston
Astros parade yes in fact he even had a
beer thrown at him I guess check this
out
[Applause]
very powerful gentleman stepped in front
I'm against this guys I am fine with
booing and I am fine with voting Ted
Cruz out I am not for throwing beers at
people's heads you could really hurt
someone uh you will never see me endorse
that type of thing unless it is
self-defense okay
so it's a waste of a beer Ted Cruz isn't
even worth the beer I'll tell you oh
that that's that's my view about the
whole thing but yes that did happen that
did indeed happen
um
other super chats if he does announce
tonight it's obvious he thinks it will
provide cover from indictment over the
stolen documents absolutely to some
degree even though Merrick Garland has
said it will not
and thanks to Samuel Crowder for the
Super Chat David I live in red Upstate
New York what are your thoughts on the
governor's race in New York I have not
been following it closely I admit so I
am not the best person to comment on it
uh but we will we will be covering it
tomorrow night for sure
uh without a doubt without a doubt so I
uh
we'll have the results it's just not a
race I've looked at very closely okay
let me say thank you to a whole bunch of
people because we have a goal of a
thousand folks listen to this
when we started with these final streams
on Thursday I said we want to get to a
thousand at the end of the Tuesday live
coverage okay we may get there tonight I
want to say thanks to softball Saul
shotx Thomas Beaver Wings rub in your
rhubarb and Sling Blade for the twitch
Prime subscriptions okay that's 853.
and then a big thank you to Chrissy
Wolfe and Jason sickmeyer for signing up
at joinpakman.com that is 8 54 and 8 55.
now I have something here for you
this is very very important stuff
let me bring this in
okay here it is
you have choices
and what you can get for eight dollars
okay
you can get a meaningless Twitter blue
check mark
okay
or you can get four memberships or four
months of membership to the David
packman show with the bonus show which
of course Alex Jones absolutely hates
globalished internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like Obama trudeoma Crown
exactly all right you have choices when
it comes to eight dollars and I will
leave it to you to judge which which
makes the most sense how many mangoes
can you get for eight dollars
I think a lot quite frankly mangoes have
come down under the Biden regime that's
for damn sure all right let's look at a
few other things here uh where are we
oh over here we are over here A bunch of
crazy stuff is happening at this Trump
rally
um
let's look at some of the stuff and
we'll have coverage of the Biden event
tomorrow we tomorrow is going to be a
crazy crazy day Trump's lawyer Christina
Bob who is also an anchor for right side
broadcasting is basically straight up
saying if we don't have every result by
like 2 A.M we're just gonna say it's
fraud we do have a better chance of
knowing who won and who lost an election
I think so I expect to know who won by
like the middle of the night maybe very
very early Wednesday morning if we don't
and if Democrats try to extend the vote
I think they're gonna have a very a very
hard time doing now remember she's
already lying to you extend the vote is
different than we just haven't counted
all of the ballots a great example is
Pennsylvania which unfortunately counts
slowly they start only when polls have
closed and I think they stop at a
relatively early hour
nobody's extending the vote did you see
how she quite literally
mixed language for two totally different
things
she's like listen I'm I think it's
absolutely fine to eat any kind of fruit
you want but at the same time people are
using apples to blow stuff up and that's
not okay and so we're gonna have to
watch that wait wait hold on a second
using fruit for explosions has nothing
to do with eating fruit why are you even
mentioning these things together I
expect to know very early but you know
if Democrats try to extend the vote
nobody's extending the vote the rules
are very clear if you're in line to vote
at the time the polls close you get to
vote they're not going to say hey you
know what it's it's Thursday I don't
know let's let more people come in and
vote it's not going to happen they are
setting this up to tell the exact same
lies doing it with any level of
credibility in 2020 they were able to do
it because they claimed covid and then
nobody was able to do anything I had
this excuse which we all know was
baloney because they had to go find more
ballots and nobody so the these are all
nobody had to hey uh we're losing let's
go look around for ballots and just I
don't know let's take a couple weeks to
figure out if there's ballots somewhere
do all of their ballot harvesting but I
think it's going to be really hard to do
tomorrow because right it's always hard
to do it's never happened they don't do
it Nobody Does it this is a lawyer this
is a lawyer very dangerous folks very
very very dangerous speaking of books I
think Brian Glenn wants to talk about oh
my goodness speaking of books such a
smooth transition by the way the new
thing is Christina Bob the woman on the
left of the screen she's not only
Trump's lawyer she's a host on on rsbn
and now she's selling a book and this
guy now is gonna like pitch the book oh
I mean the
production about President Trump and his
truth wasn't towed it also wasn't a frog
don't change because there's thanks to a
former governor of Arkansas Mike
Huckabee there's a book for that free
trumpbook.com
freetrumpbook.com that's right the rep
size says it all actually small donation
for a small fee for shipping and
handling gets that book to you but what
a great way to actually lay out the
accomplishments of President Trump and
it does man uh not the best diction for
a guy who professionally speaks for a
living that's a pretty pretty wild stuff
I want to say thank you to Tommy horse
swill and Michael Jones who just signed
up on my website pushing us to 857. also
thank you to Jory Center
blueberry babe Brown coat Loki laxer
green sauce creative pixie all of whom
just signed up via twitch Prime and
thanks to Tiny sir Jen for gifting 5
subscriptions folks we may be able to
get to a thousand tonight and if we do
we're gonna go for two on Election Day
tomorrow we're just keeping it going
okay other super chats they are just
dumping in Tiffy says serious questions
sir I live in Ohio my mother passed away
last Thursday after submitting her
absentee ballot I'm sorry to hear that
since she passed before election day
does her vote count I actually don't
know that
let's see
let's take a look here
okay 10 states allow it there are 10
states in which if you legally cast The
Ballot during the early voting period
absentee or early it still counts there
are states where it does not count you
have to Google that okay that
information is available
and I'm very very sorry to hear about
that Tiffy
Michael says Republicans would use the
polls as proof the election was stolen
if they lost and their followers would
mindlessly accept it as a fact of course
they would
Republicans in 2022 we win or else yeah
we win it was fair
we lose it was rigged
that's the bottom line
that's the bottom line let's continue
with a couple of other clips from the
rally
uh let's see what else I had here we
already played that one we did the Ted
Cruz thing
we don't have a lot of time because
Trump is expected soon and again he is
potentially going to be announcing that
he is indeed running
here is Marjorie Trader green
and I'm looking forward to serving on
committees what's with the terrible
audio at these rallies lately
[Applause]
we will be investigating and holding
people accountable there's a lot of
Traders and criminals that need to be
held accountable
okay
uh yeah I I really don't know why the
audio quality has just been so bad at
these rallies lately remember this stuff
and our incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
deal that included the largest
agricultural
is worth of our farm product at all but
I think Eric they're not like they lived
up I used to check it every week are
they buying are they buying
further screamed that his days are
numbers
[Music]
yeah I'm pretty sure on trifa is running
the uh is running the audio during these
rallies it's really crazy crazy stuff
all right couple more Clips here for
everybody let's see what else we've got
from the rally in Ohio tonight
um let's see
do we have anything even mildly
worthwhile oh uh Jr Majewski who I've
interviewed he's up there slamming Nancy
Pelosi super classy
now before I go I have to ask the
question has anybody seen the lion Tim
Ryan or that drunk nasty Nancy Pelosi or
my opponent Marcy captor here tonight
now I'm a little disappointed in that I
was hoping Timmy the ass kicker and The
Golden Girls of DC would actually show
up super good delivery huh really really
good delivery
oh yeah did you guys hear about this so
a transphobic Matt Walsh was on the
Rogan show
and he claimed that there are millions
of trans people on puberty blockers
but it seems it's it's more like a a
thousand a year how many people have had
this done
depends on what I don't think we have
exact numbers but it's if we're talking
about the drugs it's I mean Millions
um do you talk about hormone blockers
yeah but millions of kids have been on
hormone blockers really uh
I'm sure someone's going to fact check
me on there but my my guess is that
we're in we're into the millions now at
this point yeah that'll be my guess
um uh I I can say
for double mastectomies the most I've
read a report recently that
um there were over a thousand done
between 2016 and 2019 and when you
compare that to how many were done
between you know 2008 and 2015 it's just
it's a massive increase and uh over a
thousand girls that double gender
affirming double mastectomies in that in
that time frame girls you're talking
about prepubes right minors uh and
that's just up until 2019 and then we
know that uh hold on a second
prepubescent girls had their breasts
removed
do girls get breasts until puberty
does that even make sense I I genuinely
don't know do prepubescent girls have
breasts
that just doesn't sound right
people are saying no
some do
you look that up I just don't know
okay well I I mean it's it's sort of
graphic but
um
the answer is basically no
that there can be changes to the nipple
uh uh man that's that's one of those
things where you hear it you're like
wait a second pre-pubescent girls are
having their breasts removed that
doesn't really make sense uh over a
thousand girls that double gender
affirming double mastectomies in that in
that time frame girls you're talking
about prepubes right minors uh and
that's just up until oh wait now hold on
a second
he he said yes prepubescent miners now
minor could be a 17 year old
who's not prepubescent see this is this
is why this stuff is such nonsense did
you look did you listen to that closely
are you talking about prepubescent and
he says yes miners that's a completely
different thing that could be someone
who's 17 years and 10 months old
gender affirming double mastectomies in
that in that time frame girls you're
talking about prepubescent right minors
right minors
super dangerous
super super dangerous
um I'm actually I want to bookmark that
because that actually is something I
might want to cover that's crazy I mean
that that's this guy's clueless it's
unbelievable just it nothing he's saying
makes any sense
um right as people are pointing out
prepubescent and minor are two
completely different things horrifying
absolutely horrifying stuff uh so that's
that's Matt Walsh one of the foremost
authorities according to the right on
issues of gender
um prepubescent girls having breasts
from I mean it's it's wild it's really
really wild
let me get to some other super chats the
dude says David sir do you think it's
because of the Democrats having to
convince such a wide range of people to
vote for them and the Republicans only
have to get the nut cases to vote is
that why they struggle with messaging so
bad no I don't think so Democrats are
just not good at messaging and we've
talked about it extensively Matt Walsh
seems way too interested in minor
children I have noticed that he's
obsessed with with the topic uh but that
doesn't necessarily mean anything no
okay I want to say thank you to Thug
Chuckles pack fans High Gall braided
Dragon just Starly and fun fun for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
874. also big thank you to Susan Foster
Joe Rader and Lisa Rader all who just
signed up and gifted memberships on my
website now folks we are giving away
memberships almost faster than I'm able
to make lasagna which takes like 45
minutes I made one tonight if you want a
free membership simply go to
davidpackman.com free membership it's
really simple don't email me
we have memberships to give away I'll
tell people how to gift them a little
bit later but just go to
davidpackman.com free membership to ask
for a free membership how many pieces of
lasagna did I have I had one I mean it's
lasagna I'm gonna make it a half what
kind it's a uh I made a zucchini
and eggplant lasagna no I know the 45
minutes is the baking time it's
absolutely true that it took a little
longer than an hour here's the way I do
it and I know that I'll probably lose
half the audience when I explain this
there's a very simple Martha Stewart
ricotta lasagna recipe
you just add whatever you want to it you
just follow the recipe and then you add
layers of whatever you want you could do
ground beef
you could do spinach saute the spinach
and then make a layer you can do like I
did a layer of zucchini and then a layer
of that you you can just make it however
you want no no no it's it's a regular
lasagna with with pasta
and then you add the layers of
vegetables as you want so you go you
know sauce noodles
cheese eggplant
noodles Sauce Cheese zucchini
etc etc okay let's see what's going on
live as we are waiting and we are eyes
All Eyes to the Sky right now yeah okay
super simple okay super simple lasagna
don't be scared of it in fact some
people like to do lasagna on
Thanksgiving instead of going through
the entire turkey thing for me I'll do
two chickens instead of Turkey
it's like it takes four hours it's not
that good we it's just not that good
okay I recommend two beautiful
pasture-raised chickens crispy skin
takes you an hour not a problem
whatsoever okay and I'll I'll uh
continue to make that case let's listen
to a couple of voicemails here and see
what we have
hey David uh it's Thomas from South
Carolina just wanted to let you know
that I'm
I'm a younger guy I'm 17. I've been
listening to the show for about six
months now
um
I've been into politics for a few years
I was kind of on the right
until Trump came into view and then I
was like okay this has ridiculous and um
now I'm a proud Progressive
and I just wanted to let you know that I
would be if I could vote this year I
would be voting blue straight down the
ballot folks this is what I'm talking
about did you did you guys hear that
voicemail
did people hear that voicemail this is
what I'm talking about it's not
theoretical
that shows like this actually make a
difference when it comes to reaching
young voters
the right understands this they dump
money on Charlie Kirk they spend so much
money reaching people on campuses it's
because we need to be doing the Outreach
they know it works they did you hear
that perfect phone call folks
that was this is what I'm talking about
folks the right gets it
this is why you start hearing there's
more and more college students going
Republican
we should be crushing with the college
students
okay and by the way I don't even
you could make these folks Progressive
by never you don't even have to talk
about politics you can simply go to them
hey
here are tools for how to think apply
them to the real world they'll all come
out Progressive
it's not indoctrination oh by the way
people saying the Trump I I have I have
something very special for you guys
check this out
when did I send this
listen to what I found
listen tell me if this rings a bell okay
[Music]
[Music]
really makes you think
[Music]
we have a country
where 74 million people
[Music]
voted for a man who kept none of his
promises
after convincing some of the fools
that Mexico would pay for a wall
that we were obviously never going to
build
we have a country
where our airports
are filled with starbuckses
and you can't get a decent cappuccino
no matter how much you pay
I have children
who are desperate for me to love them
in particular Eric
and sadly
I don't
Baron's okay
[Music]
I make my wife call me sir
anyway
so we found the song we found the song
which is very very
exciting
for lack of a better term lack of a
better term yeah uh okay we are moments
Away Ladies and Gentlemen from the Trump
rally at which he is expected maybe to
announce that he is running
okay oh that's right hold on hold on
that that's a famous Trump line
[Music]
vivanka weren't my daughter
perhaps I would be dating her
[Music]
yeah
uh thank you to Kelly Martin Tommy horse
will and Jeremy Eiler who just signed up
on my website putting us at 880. also
thanks to Ron is twitching who signed up
via twitch and his number 881.
um
okay let's do a couple other voicemails
if I
um
can find them hey Deepak my computer's
down that's why I keep calling you but
hey that recipe Probably sounds great
the eggplant zucchini excellent done it
but uh Hey try this spaghetti squash
that comes out of the squash like
noodles and then bake it with that but
make your best spaghetti sauce whatever
you want to put in you know I'm not big
on spaghetti squash I'm actually I I got
some beautiful butternuts for tomorrow
um
but I uh I am I just I'm not huge on
spaghetti squash but I've got a great
I've got a great recipe for butternut
this is really Butternut season in the
Northeast beautiful butternut squash uh
it's yeah I know it's a very phallic
vegetable but a lot of childish uh
pranks are played with butternut squash
because it does look like a twig and
berries I will I will admit that but you
basically cut it in half and roast it
beautifully okay in the meantime saute a
bunch of mushrooms
when you take the butternut squash out
of the oven it's already caught in half
cut in half you've got like the hole in
the hole you put some cottage cheese
sprinkle the roasted mushrooms on top of
it and then you can add I like a little
bit of a of a spicy oil uh Enzo's is a
very good spicy oil a little salt and
pepper beautiful absolutely beautiful
the only issue is I can't touch
butternut squash I have a condition
called butternut squash dermatitis and I
know that people are going to laugh at
this it's a it's a legitimate Condition
it's a legitimate condition if I touch
the inside of a butternut squash my
hands become
uh red and and uh painful
and it's it's called butternut squash
dermatitis I encourage you to to look it
up it's quite a condition
um so I I will have to
figure that out I guess I would say okay
thank you very much Tyler says David sir
any thoughts on Mills versus LePage in
Maine I have not been following it
closely I admit David can't wait to hear
the Obama sound tonight well let's do it
hold on where is it where is my Obama oh
it's under glitches here it is a rhino
named rhyme name that's not Obama there
it is look how Juvenile and trumpian the
news ticker is instead of Republicans
leading by a wide margin it reads
Republicans majorly leading yeah that's
it's it's uh it's a language a trust
there are language war crimes being
committed at the bottom of the of this
broadcast for sure
David respectfully you have to get
yourself a smoker and smoke the turkey
game changer with Smoky tears in my eyes
keep up the good work sir smokers seem
like a lot of work I have never had a uh
a
smoker
thanks to RAR for signing up via twitch
Prime as we are moments away from
Trump's arrival this is a very important
evening this is the last night it's the
last night before election 2022 there is
the belief
that Donald Trump will be announcing
tonight although I believe that the RNC
did not want him to do that
um
it does appear as though Trump is kind
of pointing towards announcing tonight
now as I've told you before
I believe tonight is the beginning of
one of the craziest two-year Cycles in
American politics that we will ever have
seen when it is all said and done I
believe that because this is a setup
election
how many states can Republicans take
control of and how many seats can they
win in the House and Senate such that
they may be able to steal an election in
2024. if Trump runs in particular it
will be evident that that is their plan
we must build the left
the right gets it and the left to some
degree doesn't okay
I can talk to you about us
we're growing as much as we can
we've got the second and third YouTube
channel
we're developing and will soon be
releasing a number of different guides
and white papers
we're doing the live streams daily in
addition to the podcast we just switched
podcast platforms to better provide
features and we're we're doing
absolutely everything we can
the only thing I'm asking you for is to
show your support by getting a
membership on my website okay this is
really really really easy
and nobody's taking slices of this super
chats all these at twitch it's all great
but people are taking taking taking
taking taking
nobody takes here we just pay two
percent to swipe credit cards very
reasonable
you go to joinpakman.com
you do monthly or you do do yearly I
don't care I just want you involved
okay hit the sign up button
you see the coupon code up above my head
it's in diet forget about it do not use
that coupon code okay
use the coupon code obamna
look at this folks
look at this all right
for eight dollars
you can get a bloop check mark on
Twitter for a month
or four people can get memberships
think about that okay in all seriousness
uh this is going to be a crazy couple
years and uh I think it would be really
great to add your name to our list of
supporters we give you a lot of great
perks and I will thank every single
person who signs up if I'm able to
it does not come with a hat it does not
come with a hat uh our goal is to get to
a thousand
I think we can do it tonight my friends
I really do we're only 116 away
thanks to kahali for signing up via
twitch and if you're watching via twitch
by all means twitch counts as well if
you have Amazon Prime you get a free
twitch Prime subscription it's free it's
free
it you're getting money from Bezos and
sending it to us
which is just a great thing thanks to
Surge
who just gave out a subscription there
okay
and they sign up for subscriptions
[Music]
and then they sign up for more
subscriptions
and Independent Media grows
okay
I think it's very patriotic I know it's
extraordinarily patriotic let's do a
couple other voicemails I don't I don't
think we have a ton of time here
hey David Mike from awesome and love the
show longtime fan uh had a quick
question man so lately I've been hearing
what sounds to be like
um maybe a toddler or a small child's
voice in the middle of the podcast and
it's like a quick like shout maybe or
you know a blur and don't really hear it
again so man just picture like your your
infant out there
um running a mess in the studio maybe
you're uh your lady's chasing after or
whoever you have watching that for the
kid no that's that's producer Pat you
must have heard wrong that's that's
producer Pat whining in the background
uh no in all seriousness yeah my my
studio is temporarily at home because
we're in the middle of a relocation of
the studio which by the way
new studio is going to be nice your
studio is going to be very nice and
occasionally what my daughter now has
taken to doing is basically screaming
her way into naps she's down to three
naps a day but she wants to nap
but she insists on screaming into the
nap
and uh
you know
it's not the most exciting moment of the
day let's say
but we deal with it the best we can
that's for damn sure but no let's go
with
it's it's producer Pat whining
hey David what is your very powerful
position on dates and by date I mean the
crew States
thanks for all you do bro I think dates
are great uh a really really great and
people will say oh sir there's so much
sugar in dates okay yeah there's some
sugar in it the dates have sugar but
it's not it's not a refined sugar and
they're high in fiber one of the great
things you can do with dates
is you open up the date and you cut it
in half and you stick an almond
right in there
bite it together delicious some people
will add peanut butter
you could add just like a little you
could add like a super dark chocolate
chip to it
great very very good snack I highly
highly support dates let's put it that
way thanks to Mother Roo Trekker bear
and Toki token
who are subscribed via twitch Prime
this is a dystopian
totalitarian moment
these Rubes have been built out of their
money
to support a guy who doesn't give two
shits about them
and he uses the money to refurbish his
plane
and now he shows up with the plane
and they cheer
these people have been scammed to high
heaven
it's really something else really
something else
folks we are experiencing
massive dumps of memberships right now
on the website
I want to say thank you to the following
people okay this is this is absolutely
stunning
thank you to Sean fertel Catherine nail
Snick Nico pulos
Andrew kravetsky Jason sigmeyer Neil
Bradley Stuart Crawford Jake Olson
Nicholas Scott Samuel Crowder
Shamari Vasquez Andy van John Deering
Jonathan McNally Cody clay
Elizabeth hook Alexander riojas Julie
Farrer and Vanessa Gaylor they all just
signed up on my website that is 17.
putting us at 904. whoops where are we
there we go
folks
we may get to a thousand tonight
thanks to Mo mokans and jetstorm
for the twitch Subs that's 906
welcome to Zach Collis Paul howitt and
Michael Brown new members on my website
putting us at 909. I I'm doing the best
I can with names I'm sure at some point
I'm gonna have a moment like Trump
but not yet not yet Jack Henry newest
member that's a name I can pronounce
with confidence David Thomas welcome
David I know I'm getting that one right
uh it's really great to have people here
it's daily streams we're gonna be here
we'll be here tomorrow we're going to be
here late tomorrow I hope that you will
join me uh be darn Dandy says Hey from
Germany our media is increasingly
covering your elections and we're
horrified the world is watching and it's
not looking good I agree with you
I agree with you
David can't lie I'm worried about where
our country is heading and where it'll
be 20 years 10 to 20 years from now the
election is Uber important I agree Kyle
listen that's that's why we're here
that's why we're here
thanks to newbie gaming tlang and Pac
fans as well as snora
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
welcome to Steven grapp Alex Raider and
Alex Cobb who just signed up on my
website
uh we're seeing an acceleration here
ladies and gentlemen I think we may be
doing this tonight
Kellen Lutz and Kendra mock welcome
new members number 9 19 and 9 20.
I am stunned by what is happening Becky
says I'm sat here at stupid o'clock in
the UK watching this madness unfold with
my heart and mouth I am trans and my
partner lives in the USA I am honestly
fearing for the future more and more
I'm with you Becky
I am with you and if Trump announces
tonight expect this crowd to go
absolutely bonkers
bonkers
Bonkers if Trump announces Tabitha
McCord Sean sirif and CJ Coker just
signed up on my website putting us at 9
23. Mr pepper Mark English and fun with
knives just signed up via twitch Prime
danger shots just gifted 10.
folks are we gonna do it before Trump
even speaks
James Hogue and Matthew Harris just
signed up on my website putting us at 9
38.
should I do a care package for number
1000 if we make it
David what are the chances the polling
is way off there's a good chance the
polls are off by two or three points
that could be all the difference
so vote vote vote
vote vote vote the polls very well could
be off by two or three points
tonight Donald J Jump will vary Donald J
Trump will very very possibly likely
certainly almost assuredly announce his
intention to stop teaching transgender
exactly right
uh wait do I even have my teach
transgender thing
further scream that his days are
numbered oh no I don't have it okay I've
got to get that going do you feel this
Maga type movement was always coming in
time and Trump accelerated it or did he
create most of it no he didn't create it
he coalesced it and he made a lot of
those people feel really confident
about publicly talking about their views
uh chemek music is the newest twitch
Prime subscriber putting us at 9 39.
Remember When the Right Said the left
was glorifying and turning Obama into a
celebrity now look at them I know
I know
David do you think if Trump announces
tonight it will tank the Red Wave I hope
so
I'm still not convinced there is a red
wave coming
let's wait and see
sir thoughts on Elon Musk publicly
endorsing Republicans on Twitter have
you considered migrating to an
alternative platform like Mastodon I
don't even know what that is
um decentralized social media never
heard of it you know part of it is
you've got to be where the people are if
if the people leave Twitter by the way
then that that'll be interesting I think
musk is out of his mind
um I think he's kind of one of these
reactionary Libertarians
um kind of like a Tulsi
and I don't I don't find it very
impressive
thanks to Tiny sir Jen for gifting a
twitch Prime subscription
Shack nasty Dingus wow also the newest
twitch Prime
subscriber welcome to Angie Yohi
Michelle Bullard Jonas Stoltz Martin
Fillion Brit Alexander and Stephen Slama
that's one two three four five six
folks are this is going to be like a
photo finish I think we may be able to
get to a thousand before Trump even says
a word here Ross Jax has just signed up
via twitch listen folks subscriber 1000
gets a special care package from my
website
four free items
you can get the Hat
the mug the shirt and the hoodie okay
number one thousand
gets this and the bumper sticker yes
five items
five items
number one thousand I think we're gonna
be able to do it welcome to Willa Chong
as well as Sarah Coleman
that puts a set 950.
super chats are dumping in
oh and those I did David sir I love the
message and want to buy a membership but
I don't trust you people with my
information can I have come in person to
get a membership no
uh that's completely insane welcome to
Johnny manogue as well as Aaron asbill
and Stephen Slama with another gift
putting us at 9 53 As Trump gets ready
to exit Bernie on a boat and Miss
Buddakan putting us at 9 55.
elements of airplane bathrooms how many
flushes does Trump need for that golden
airplane toilet I can't imagine Trump's
getting good suction on a 757. I don't
believe it for a second long Souls
thanks for the twitch Prime started
watching the show since 2020 love
everything you talk about on the show
you sir are no fake news thank you Tad
I don't have a car says Sean well thank
you for that information
I appreciate that
good to know
welcome to Kenneth Plummer Jeremiah
hegler Andrew Culp Martin Fillion and
Shelley Martin gifting and subscribing
at joinpakman.com
that is
four
putting us at 961.
welcome to Kelly odle number 962. we
will be live tomorrow folks the listen
if it's bad tomorrow we can we can
welcome that
begrudgingly but together
and we might be pleasantly surprised
tomorrow night
I'm leaving it at that we might be
pleasantly surprised crystal says can we
drop president from Trump's
introductions he doesn't deserve the
respect or dignity that accompanies the
title what about trader Trump I've been
calling him failed former president
dust says Super Chat thank you
thanks to love to draw appreciate that
fun fun art van delay Hyatt and Pac fans
thank you via twitch puts us at 966.
thanks to Peyton Manning for gifting a
subscription as well as Wendell sealed
putting us at 968
Kyle Noble says what are your thoughts
on banjos I'm generally in favor but
have no interest whatsoever in playing
one myself
no interest at all welcome to Julianna
Newbold and Brandon Spencer let's go
Brandon let's do it putting us at 970
folks Trump is moments away
first aid
is very strongly supporting the stream
as is extend The Feelers via twitch as
the Trump propaganda video plays he may
be announcing tonight that is the latest
reporting that we are getting
a horrifying horrifying situation
the election tomorrow yes Republicans
favored I do believe the polling may be
a little overly favorable towards
Republicans and I think anything could
happen you had damn weather damn well
better vote tomorrow
thanks to nuclei pasta for the twitch
Prime subscription putting us at 9.73
welcome to Simon Reed Kelly Moran and
Michael Kennison who just signed up on
my perfect website putting us at 9.76.
gwj says I live in PA I can't wait to
powerfully vote for fetterman and
Shapiro tomorrow absolutely
absolutely
Rusty Tamp
is new member number 977 via twitch
Andrew Culp Justin
at and Stefan Brown have just signed up
and gifted subscriptions on the website
by the way folks we have so many gifts
to give away if you want a free
membership I would I would put your name
in now at davidpackman.com free
membership why not we've got probably
two hours of trump ranting coming up so
everybody I hope you've got snacks water
everything you need
David sir what's your position on
hybrids do you think they're just as
good as electric vehicles No in fact I
do not recommend hybrids at all one of
the issues with hybrids is the the
pricing differential from the hybrid to
the gas the fully gas powered
um
is typically not worth the gas savings
unless you drive some crazy amount I am
ready to say I would not buy a hybrid
vehicle I would either Buy
the most efficient standard in internal
combustion engine vehicle I can find or
get a full electric vehicle
I would not get a hybrid
call me crazy
call me crazy but I don't do it I would
not do it thanks to Pac fans and Andrew
X for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 982.
thank you to Grant bullert
Stephen Heap
Conrad Fitzsimmons Marilou Resnick
Brandon Spencer Mario Jimenez and Harold
Purdy that's one two three four five six
seven
ladies and gentlemen
can we do it we are at 989 welcome to
Roland trophin number 990. folks this is
it number 1000 gets anything they want
from my online store merging magpies is
9.91.
when your grandkids say to you
where were you
when they hit a thousand you will know
exactly where you were
look at these super chats lurking for
months thanks for what you do thanks
ruthanne
can we have a poll of who voted already
yes
please post in the chat if you have
already voted that is interesting
all right I already addressed banjos
already did that
all right folks here we go
Leslie Arnold Andrew Culp Mario Jimenez
gifts two three four
and five
two three hold on a second I gotta make
sure we get the right person for a
thousand one two three four five six
seven
I don't want to miss who is one thousand
okay that's 9.98. let's do this very
carefully now okay
Stephen Slama just gifted another one
that's 9.99 and new member number one
thousand
is Chris lindtner
Chris lintner you are new member number
1000 folks we're going for fifteen
hundred
email info davidpackman.com there's Eric
Trump looking visibly confused visibly
confused I'm guessing they're all here
because Trump's announcing I don't think
they would all be here if Trump was not
announcing I think it is clear Trump is
announcing tonight and he is going to
unleash hell upon this planet the likes
of which we have never seen before
I believe Trump is announcing
memberships continue to dump in
okay look at this ladies and gentlemen
look at this spinach monster five
Anonymous Relic canimation Lucifer tiger
girl that's nine girl Jesse gifting 10
more
switcher suite and Anonymous gifter
that's 11.
we're at a Thousand Eleven and the
website is about to crash from what's
Happening Martin Fillion
Nico poulos Mario Jimenez Mario Jimenez
Mario Jimenez Brandon Spencer Caleb
sickles Simon Reed Steve Slama Mario is
back in Pac-Man is my daddy
Stephen Slama Andrew Culp Mario Jimenez
Thomas Neal and David Henkel folks the
website's about to crash
under the load of memberships
it's it's not we're about we're about to
go down
okay that's 16 putting us at a thousand
twenty nobody has ever seen numbers like
this
super chats continue to come in this is
way too over the top for a regular rally
my bet is he's announcing I believe
Trump is announcing
his entire family is here and they're
right up by the stage I believe he is
announcing and I believe this is going
to unleash hell on Earth
Mrs Fields and AJ Scorpio
are adding their names via twitch
I hope everyone is following and has
subscribed
because we we've got to be here for the
election results tomorrow folks okay
if you have not yet subscribed to the
YouTube channel
please do so
oh my goodness look at these numbers
everything is exploding look at this
oh my God it's like a slot machine out
here
we are going to be here tomorrow night
we will be here on Twitch
we will be here on Facebook we will be
here on YouTube
the most important midterm election
results I've ever covered
and potentially the most consequential
okay
we're gonna be here
some people saying they still don't
think Trump is going to be announcing
tonight
um
I mean his whole family's here which is
odd
I see Trump I see the subscriptions
continuing to dump in we will keep the
counter up to date
this may be the start of 2024.
there's too many subscriptions Mick
can't take it anymore I know did they
confirm he's wanting to run with the
Trump 2024 mug ads and new slogan I
don't know
I don't know I I didn't see it
welcome to Chef Ramsey
as well as mother Roo tiku blueberry
babe Leslie from Colorado Springs as
well
everybody's here today
are they playing the song
they are
um let's see if Newsmax covers it
thanks to Brandon Spencer as well as
Tracy Leonard
and Cole Miller folks I am flattered by
your support I hope every single one of
you is going to be here tomorrow night
because it's going to be a big big deal
I'm not sure Trump is announcing tonight
but it's been teased
Trump teased it his family is at the
rally
so there are certainly signs of
something happening
Richard says Trump's like a baby who had
his rattle taken away then got Freaky
Friday into his dad's body and decides
to take revenge
I'm scared both as a woman and disabled
person I don't want him back in the
White House you and me both Corinne
thanks for all you do David it might be
a miserable week let's pray for sanity
yeah
here we go folks this is a big crowd
this is a beautiful big crowd hello Ohio
hello hello hello hello
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
I do wish the fake news would show this
crowd this is massive this is incredible
this is incredible I'm thrilled to be
back
in this wonderful state with the
thousands of proud hard-working American
Patriots you built this country thank
you very much tomorrow the great people
of Ohio are going to send JD Vance to
the United States Center
and you're going to re-elect Mike dewine
as you even though States government
and John is as lieutenant governor
you're going to vote for an incredible
slate of true American first Republicans
up and down the ballot and we are going
to end crazy Nancy Pelosi's political
career
once and for all
right that's right
hello
under Biden Pelosi Schumer and the
radical democrat congress the great
state of Ohio is under siege you know
that better than anyone I didn't know
Biden and the far left lunatics are
Waging War on Ohio energy workers just
yesterday Biden bragged
that on his watch there is quote no more
drilling you know that's not what he
said JD sounds good Ed he said it
yesterday didn't quite know what he was
saying then they tried to correct it
today they said you didn't understand
the meaning it's too early for that
sorry guys no he said no more drilling
right
but the energy costs in this country are
skyrocketing like nobody's ever seen
before and so the food costs and so is
every other cost and you're paying a big
price like a thousand dollars a month in
Ohio
that's right
at his at his Saturday rally he said
inflation is costing people 700 extra
dollars a month at yesterday's rally he
said it's costing people 800 a month and
tonight he said it's a thousand he's
making this [ __ ] up every single month
[Music]
this other border we had a southern
border was the best ever that was a
glitch it's wide open now millions and
millions of illegal aliens are pouring
into our Country violent crime is out of
control in the far left is
indoctrinating our children with Twisted
race and gender insanity
in our schools like we've never even
thought of before this was never even
thought of before
this country has gone crazy
there's only one choice to end this
madness if you support the decline fall
of America then you must
absolutely must vote for the radical
left crazy people the radical left
Democrats and if you want to stop the
destruction of our country and save the
American dream then tomorrow you must
vote Republican in a giant red wave that
we've all been hearing about Dear God
there is no more urgent task for the
future of our country than to stop The
Invasion on our Southern border two
years ago we had the strongest Southern
Border in American history there was
nothing even close now it's the worst
border perhaps in the history of the
world anywhere you know I can find you
some borders that are pretty much
non-functional I don't think that that's
true
not at all two years six and Stones if
they had to use them give me a stick and
give me a stone they wouldn't allow this
to happen to a country even at a third
world level and I hate to tell you our
country is becoming third world that's
what's happening to us
Biden Pelosi and the radical Democrats
spend all their time obsessing over the
borders of distant foreign Nations
Americans deserve a Congress and a
president who will protect the borders
of our nation don't you think
and very simply it's called America
first we came up with that little
name and you know they say on the other
side we will not let America First
dominate they should really say we don't
like Trump's policies but you don't say
we don't want America first and then
they go after Maga all the time we will
stop Maga well Maga means make America
great again you know it's it's uh
they're pretty tough to stop JD and good
hey JD you have some very good polls I
saw today what the hell am I doing here
good night everyone
that'd be great
we can make this one real short JD would
you like to just do it for a quickie
yeah would you want to go through the
whole deal no no no Uncle Sam what do
you want to do Uncle Sam we love Uncle
Sam you know we have incredible women
here from North Carolina and they were
with us yesterday in Miami did you see
where we had a tropical storm
and it came down I've never had rain
like that I've never seen anything like
it everything was so beautiful
and we did it for Marco Rubio and he is
doing really well I will tell you he's
doing really well our people are doing
well JD but all of a sudden the song
went off you know the song people love
it they love that last bit do you like
it
I like it it's terrible I like doing it
to me it's beautiful it's more would
anybody like to see me stop doing that
we'll do a poll free poll yeah please
don't do it anymore so who wants to do
it oh God
and who doesn't want to do it
so you know what I just did I saved a
million dollars to upholster
you know no they interviewed 203 people
and they tell you that's a much better
poll I agree yeah no it's beautiful but
the music went on and it was like
somebody took a large pail of water and
dropped it on my head
and uh we said I I was I had a problem
because the teleprompters were useless
okay they were absolutely teleprompters
he doesn't use like loser Obama weren't
functioning perfectly
and had a choice and they said please
come off the stage you know security
please come off the stage well there was
no lightning so we didn't have danger
but I've never seen anything this was
like the worst shower you've ever taken
it was just pouring and you know in
Florida it goes like that for about 10
or 15 minutes and it stops the Sun comes
out it's very quick but it's brutal so
I'm doing it and I had to throw away the
teleprompters and we did so well and I
was saying what do you think would have
happened to Biden if that happened I
don't think it would have been too good
I don't think it would have been too
good man he is obsessed with Biden huh
it was actually people have said today
it was like a religious experience the
people the music comes on and then boom
we just got it was like unbelievable
I've never seen anything like it you
know it's funny he said that when the
sun came out on his inauguration day it
was a sign from God yesterday when it
started raining it was a religious
experience I guess then it all kind of
zeros out because no matter what it was
God no planned obsolescence they can
make a windshield wiper that would last
100 years but they make them only so
they last exactly one year and then you
have to buy a new one which means
they're smart okay
let's let him keep to but you ever do
that where you're driving and you can't
see well that's what I had with my one
little remaining teleprompter so we had
to go and we had a great evening yeah uh
one of the greatest rallies we've ever
had and it was caused by God sending us
the heaviest rain I've ever seen it was
unbelievable must be a sign and nobody
left the media didn't even leave the
fake news oh look at all of them wow
remember reports are half the crowd left
during Trump's last two speeches before
they were over so lot of fake news back
there
I'm looking at Eric and Don Trump
they're so lucky I allowed them to get
into politics right they've been treated
so kindly
these are the two most subpoenaed human
beings in history Al Capone
you ever hear of Alphonse Capone the
legendary Jesse James Billy the Kid
these two have had more
investigations and Jesse James ability
to come from Congress you know Maxine
Waters set us up you know because she's
a very honest person dad
she's the very honest person dad
no no I think they set a record most
subpoenaed human beings in the history
of the world
but you know the good news has been
going on for six years we're very honest
a friend of mine said you have to be the
most honest person ever there you go
years and years millions and millions of
pages of documents JD they checked every
deal they checked deals that I forgot
about
and I said I don't remember I get a call
from a guy did a deal 22 years ago hi Mr
President I just wanted to let you know
we were just visited by the
law enforcement authorities on what that
deal we did about 23 years ago oh how's
it doing well we sold it about five
times already
people I haven't heard from them years
they get visited by these are sick
people these are sick people but this is
what we're going through JD you got to
get it stopped because that's going to
be that's the beginning of Communism
it's the beginning of Communism wow the
police which they claim to support doing
their jobs is now communism we are not
we've skipped over that that's gone
socialism is gone for about uh a year
already I think we're into the world of
Communism right now last year an average
of 14 Ohio lives were lost to drug
overdoses every single day yet Biden and
the radical Democrats do nothing to stop
the lethal poisons pouring across our
borders and we had it almost stopped we
had the safest borders ever that
included
human trafficking and it included drugs
but it included people we sent thousands
and thousands of MS-13 back we I'll tell
you what ice and Border Patrol and law
enforcement but they do a great job they
do a great job
Brandon Judd Tom Holman these are
incredible people since the end of the
Trump Administration the drug cartels
have seen their revenue Skyrocket by an
astounding listen to this one you
business people you think you're good at
business you're nothing compared to
these people two thousand five hundred
percent would you say that's good if
that were stock on the New York Stock
Exchange it would be the hottest stock
of the decade
the choice this election is simple
Democrats will defund the police
Republicans will defund the cartels no
Democrats are running on defund none
under my leadership we wage war on the
cartels we ended Catch and Release we
stopped Asylum fraud and we threw
illegal alien gang members out of our
country by the thousands and we got
their countries Guatemala
Honduras we got their countries to take
them back JD you know they wouldn't take
them back under the under the Obama
Barack Hussein Obama under the Obama
Administration they refused they refused
to take him back they said no we're not
taking them back so I said I tell this
it's uh unbelievable primarily three but
there are others too and I said how much
do we pay uh them every year what do we
give them 750 million dollars sir that's
a lot I said we're not going to pay him
any more stop payment it's like a stop
payment of a check we stop payment
and let them know because they're not
taking back the people that they sent
over you know they send those people
over these are very smart they don't
just happen to come right when you have
these guys come over that look rougher
than any prize fighter you've ever seen
these are rough people tough people they
empty their prisons into our country I
said send them back send them back and
if they don't take them you know they
put airplanes on their Runway so when
our plane goes back loaded with these
people that have to be out of our
country they said no you can't land you
can't land you have no Runway you can't
land so I said good stop this at 750
million the following day
I got a call from the head of Honduras
nice man by the way very and very smart
very Street wise I'll tell you what JD
these are StreetWise people these are
smart people they're at the top of their
game unlike others that we know about
these are all these leaders are all this
is the prototypical Trump rant that's
going nowhere nobody in the crowd knows
what's going on and almost certainly
none of what Trump is saying actually
happened certainly not the way he's
telling it Guatemala get a call from El
Salvador they are principal three now
it's everybody it's 129 different
countries we had last week 129 different
countries but they said sir we don't
understand and they call separately
almost like eight o'clock in the morning
but I work early so I said yes Mr
President what is it sir I understand
you stop payment on the money that you
send us on a weekly basis I said how
much is it well we get 250 million I
said yeah we're stopping payment you're
never getting it again because you don't
take these people back you sent them
here
in the Caravans you sent them and now
we're going to send them back and he
said oh I didn't know there was a
misunderstand they've only been trying
for 10 years to get them back but nobody
did this one and he said you know
honestly sir we would be honored to take
them back we love MS-13 gang members
very very much we think they're
wonderful people we would love to have
them back in there in our country and I
got the other two calls within about 20
minutes all three calls within a half
hour I got and within 45 minutes they
agreed or we were sending them back by
the thousands and thousands and
thousands and then this Administration
so Trump keeps saying thousands and
thousands of thousands of Ms 13. it
appears as though total ever
1300 MS-13 members were deported
Okay thousands and thousands and
thousands and just this one one incident
seems like it's thirteen hundred ever
they're gonna be paying a price we've
got to get them out
we gotta get them out we built hundreds
of miles of Border walls and despite two
and a half years of democrat lawsuits to
stop it and we won them all many many
lawsuits we completely finished our
original wall plan we had a border wall
plan that was beautiful remember the
promise was
entire 1900 miles of wall done in one
term paid for by Mexico he did not
accomplish that completed the job in
three weeks but the radical left
Democrats didn't want to do that job
that's when I got why so the fact I said
you know I really think they want open
borders to ravage our country and every
day these Democrat policies are getting
innocent Americans killed and killed in
large numbers earlier this year and
MS-13 gang member was sentenced for
helping lure a teenage boy to a
playground beating him in the head with
a baseball bat and brutally stabbing him
32 times this was an animal Nancy Pelosi
said please don't call them animals
they're human beings I said no they're
animals
of course I think she's an animal too
you want to know the truth oh
disgusting
they'll say oh what a horrible thing he
said about dancing she impeached me
twice for nothing
they'll say this is like saying a police
a police officer is bad because they
arrested me for a crime I committed
terrible let me tell you what she does
to this country and what she did to the
and the turmoil and it was all I used
the word yesterday shouldn't my great
first lady got very upset I said I will
never use the word again
but what she did to us
in this country and yet we got more done
as an Administration and a president
than just about any president in the
history of our country in four years
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
Boston last year an illegal alien Visa
overstayer tried to rob a father of 12
children before
stamping him eight times now of course
what's interesting about Visa overstayer
is
they just want to build a wall they
never talk about Visa over stairs their
entire plan is a wall to Target what is
actually the minority of those here
illegally
but now all of a sudden dude you did
nothing about the Visa over stairs take
immediate action to force the
restoration of all of our policies all
they had to do is leave it alone we had
the greatest Border in history I'll tell
you a hundred times leave it alone we
had it so good and it was getting better
and stronger and stronger the drugs were
down the lowest they were in 32 years
and now the drugs are seven times to ten
times higher than when we had it only
two years ago think of it the drugs are
pouring in I told president XI of China
no more fentanyl we're not going to do
any business we're not going to let you
do any business and you know it was
getting stopped now it's gone crazy what
they've done is unbelievable it's been
Unleashed I want to do one thing because
I think it's very important to do it
this is visit close to 100 of a group of
very beautiful I'm not allowed to say
that so I won't they're very beautiful
nevertheless
young women from North Carolina this is
I think there are 100th rally
and they were so good and actually
that's peanuts compared to Uncle Sam
here and some of these people they
followed me no matter where the hell I
go I see Uncle Sam Uncle Sam there he is
Uncle Sam is driving me crazy where's
Uncle Sam you're the greatest look at
Uncle Sam
there he is look at this guy
[Applause]
and that's not a stage you know this
guy's for real but you know he loves
Uncle Sam do you love our country
ah you better believe it no he loves it
better two years ago but you're gonna
love it a lot very soon so he
interrupted himself in praising the
North Carolina women
this guy
he's actually better looking than the
real Uncle Sam if you wanna but these
ladies are obviously very well to do
they're so magnificently attired and
they follow the tour they go with the
tour so this is the real like a rock
star JD because we have a tour we have a
lot of people see the front row Joe's
these front row Joe's these are serious
people and you know what they're all
successful they make money they've got
cars and trucks that cost a fortune you
got to see the paint job I call them
sometimes if I want something painted I
said who the hell painted the beautiful
flag on your truck the talent they have
is incredible but we love our front row
Joe's but you know and they've been here
for three four days waiting I'm
surprised you don't get better treatment
than that like you can't work a deal
with one of our guys to get in without
all the wedding but you actually like
the wedding right it's like a tailgate
party a lot of people they hear they
started here four days ago we've had
some place that's super cult lead that's
Jim jones-esque you like waiting for me
outside in the cold for nine days right
it builds character
look at this they're like Central
Casting
I mean how beaut
I'm not allowed to use that term anymore
it used to be you could say they're
beautiful women today if you use that
term they say what a horrible thing that
he is but you are beautiful women look
at them rambling
we're close to a hundred right close to
a hundred unbelievable they travel from
North Carolina they're all married I
don't know what their husbands must be
thinking how are you doing with the
husbands are you okay the marriages are
intact
no but sometimes the husbands come too I
think as little as possible I don't
think they want the husbands to come
but you're great thank you very much we
appreciate it thank you you're really
great great people
great great people instead of doubling
the number of IRS agents we should
double the number of ice and border
patrol agents
and we should pass legislation to deport
every illegal alien that Joe Biden has
unlawfully allowed to break into our
country
we're going to make America great again
and we are going to do it first we have
to make America safe again it's not safe
we don't have a safe country anymore you
know in Afghanistan I was very tough on
Afghanistan remember that generally
speaking the violent crime rate in the
U.S continues to decline would you call
the Taliban because that's where I
remember Jesse James why do you rob the
banks he said that's where the money is
why do you call the leader the Taliban
that's where the problem was right and
Abdul and I got along with a very nice
lady they hate when I say that I got
along with Kim Jong-un very nice isn't
it good that I got along with him right
we didn't end up in a nuclear war you
would have ended up in a nuclear war at
that time believe me probably you could
end up in another one A different one
with him and also Russia and also others
because our people don't know what the
hell they're doing okay but so we have
so many things happening that were
called them
unforced errors inflation should have
never happened
things inflated in fact energy is less
than many other things forget about
buying a turkey for Thanksgiving has
anybody bought your turkey yet for
Thanksgiving because if you haven't
don't even waste your time number one
you probably won't get it and if you do
you're going to pay approximately three
times more I was just at two grocery
stores they were filled with turkeys
also I don't know why you would buy it
yet but by bloodthirsty gangs and
violent Criminal as much of the crime
wave has caused by drug dealers who
during the course of their lives will
kill an average of 500 Americans think
that is untrue there is no evidence
there is no mathematical case to justify
that claim he's made it dozens of times
his followers repeat it it's not true
Africans which will upon its passage
reduce drug distribution and reduce
crime in our country by a minimum of 75
percent on the first day that this
policy is instituted in one day that's
75 of the crime will go down it was an
election again if you did and I don't
like to bring this up it's a tough
subject nobody I don't know if the
country is ready for it I can tell you
with President XI in China I see him
say president you have 1.5 billion
people do you have a drug problem no no
no drug problem quick trial I say how do
you do that I really sort of knew but I
didn't want to how do you do that
and then he probably thought I was
somewhat and I if he goes we have quick
trial I said what's a quick try I think
I knew what that was too that means they
catch a drug dealer they give them a
quick trial not a trial that takes
12 years
and 12 years of appeals 25 years later
and everyone's dead by the time they get
to the end of that no this is a trial
that takes approximately two hours right
and if they're guilty they are
executed and
the and the bullet and you know the
bullet I don't know if anybody wants to
know this it gets a little bit too
graphic but the bullet is said to their
families you know that right
do you know that it's actually sent to
their families it's pretty tough stuff
there's no Trump just loves dictatorial
stuff he's just so impressed by it he's
he wants to be a dictatorship
absolutely not what are you talking
about of course we don't because we
don't play games you look at Singapore
you look at other countries wherever
they have the death penalt zero drug
problems drugs are causing us tremendous
problem and unless you do this I'm tired
of Blue Ribbon committees you know I set
up these wonderful Blue Ribbon
committees composed of
diplomats people like uh nice people
Society ladies from New York they they
care but this is you're dealing with
very very vicious very smart very tough
people making a fortune you have to get
tough and if you don't do the death
penalty you'll never stop crime in this
country as great as our police are and
they're great we have to give them back
their Authority but you can stop 75 80
percent of the crime in this country
with the proper passage of a meaningful
bill and it's got to be done I don't
like being the one to say it some people
Everyone agrees you know it's
interesting because Trump was President
for four years and it turned out none of
these things actually work the way
claimed and he did not none of them he
accomplished nothing that and there are
quite a few they have no no problem
whatsoever with the Republican Congress
we must also pass critical funding to
hire thousands more police officers
Nationwide and put violent criminals
Behind Bars and keep them behind bars
we need to let our police do their job
we love our police and only look they
know what to do but they're prevented
from doing their job unless it's the FBI
investigating him in which case the
police are clueless of course
look you got to get these people out of
office they gotta leave
because they're killing our country to
fund the police
how about defund the police there is a
city I won't mention because I know some
very good people no National Democrats
are running on defund the police it's
just not happening robbed
and you call the police and they'll show
up they'll do the best they can to show
up eight hours later you know that story
if you're being accosted Uncle Sam if
you're being accosted in a certain
number of cities it takes hours and
hours for the police to come and then
they wanted to fund the police and it
has to be just the opposite so vote
Republicans up and down the line we all
agree we got a stop crime the Democrats
are a catastrophe every single Democrat
city is a disaster without exception
there is no exception
and the Republican cities and the
Republican states run very well and
that's not because I'm out here to
promote a product I'm not but that's the
way it is you look at the list 25 out of
25 the most dangerous places on Earth
again more dangerous than Afghanistan
when I told Abdul
don't kill ourselves they were killing a
lot of soldiers they're snipers
losing a lot under the
look under the Obama Administration it
was a disaster and I said don't do it
Abdul
don't do it but why but why he said but
why do you send me a picture of my house
I said because I think you have a
beautiful house Abdul
don't kill any more of our great
soldiers
and from that call on 18 months and you
know what Biden actually used it in one
of his speeches and they they really rep
they were screaming at him to don't say
that they didn't want because it's good
18 months not one that never happened
Soldier was killed for 18 months until
the disaster at the airport which should
have never taken place because you don't
move the soldiers out first you move the
soldiers at last
one of the worst and most Sinister
aspects of the Biden Administration is
that complete and total Corruption of
our justice system and the rule of law
before our very eyes Biden and his
left-wing handlers are turning America
into a police state that's what we're
turning into a police state
they want to get rid of all the police
and they're turning America into a
police state
with the defunded police that they're
getting rid of right I mean makes
perfect sense they're political
opponents silencing dissent and using
the full force of government law
enforcement and the media to try and
defeat our movement and by the way
Catherine Engelbrecht of Truth to vote
was led out of prison today
it's called true the vote he doesn't
even know the name of the organization
it's it's just nonsense she was studying
the tapes thousands of hours along with
Incredible Patriots many many men and
women they had a team and they did you
know 2 000 mules and uh amazing job
I don't know if you know that a week ago
they put her in prison and you know why
they made up some excuse about not
revealing a source well how about
revealing the source that leaked the
information from the Supreme Court why
don't you do something with that person
uh-huh
they put her in prison because she
wouldn't reveal but they didn't put the
reporter in prison who knows who that
person is right you could find that very
easily wow the Supreme Court could find
that very easily that information to the
Supreme Court because I think the
leaking
from the Supreme Court first time it's
ever happened is just unbelievable but
you get the information very easily see
other right-wingers have stopped talking
about that because it's pretty clear at
this point that it was a right-winger
who leaked it it's bye bye
the Reporter Goes to Jail and when the
reporter learns that he's going to be
married in two days to a certain
prisoner that's extremely strong tough
and mean
he will say so that's Trump joking about
prison rape really really a good subject
huh it could get me the hell out of here
every freedom-loving American needs to
understand the time to stand up to this
growing left-wing tyranny is right now
if you want to save your rights and
Liberties you have to start by dealing a
humiliating rebuke to the radical left
in this election this is so important
this election J.D Vance
you know his opponent is making me like
I'm his best friend I don't know this
guy but he's far left he voted with
Obama I think he voted with Obama and
with Biden he's really been he's he said
Obama now multiple rallies in a row he
really seems to be struggling with that
one Obama of trump I think Trump is
wonderful I don't know the gentleman I
can tell you this he's not for us he's a
radical left lunatic who's now trying to
jump on the bandwagon because that stuff
failed so badly but they're not going to
stop they're going to continue to go on
with it tomorrow you have to crush the
Communists because that's what they are
at the Battle should be easy there
aren't any eight years the witch hunts
hoaxes and abuses have been coming Fast
and Furious they are abuses and they are
hoaxes first we learned they spied in my
campaign can you imagine didn't happen
can you imagine if we spied on
Barack Hussein Obama literally did not
happen it would be the death penalty you
get the death penalty and go Sam death
penalty right they would reinstitute
the death penalty Trump spied on Obama
can you imagine he's extra unhinged
tonight truly it happens
and then you have a guy like Bill Barr
he's so petrified of being impeached he
doesn't want to do it I'm sure they'll
go to impeach me I said I got impeached
twice my 12 numbers went up what's the
big deal sure sure I told him but he
didn't want to be impeached he didn't
want
no sir the election was beautiful you
know two months before he was talking
about how corrupt everything was with
the election
the U.S attorney from Pennsylvania he
wrote a letter saying Barr would not let
him investigate Philadelphia which was
so corrupt so corrupt and the
Philadelphia court you know just ruled
that it was corrupt and they said it was
all all those ballots hundreds of
thousands of ballots were invalid that
it
the Court ruled about primary ballots
this year without a date on them it had
nothing to do with 2020 and Trump's
election
do you think he knows that and he knows
his followers are too stupid to know the
difference or do you think even Trump
doesn't know what that Court said tied
to Congress they lied to the fisa court
and created a fake dossier that wasn't
good for me to go home that night and
explain to the first lady that was not a
good dossier JD you never want to have
to do that
never that was not good but she actually
believed me she said I know that's not
your thing you know I don't know if you
notice people are already starting to
leave the rally they wait all day to
hear Trump
and then I don't know if it's so boring
or it just gets too late there was a
report that and in Latrobe half the
audience left while Trump was still
speaking when they zoom out you already
see people leaving paid for by crooked
Hillary and the Democrats and yet after
all of their lies and all of their
corruption these same people keep coming
after me they keep coming after Trump
remember first it was Russia Russia
Russia that it was Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine remember that the perfect phone
call and the Mueller Witch Hunt where
the conclusion was no collusion think of
that the conclusion was no collusion now
do you think Biden can say that I don't
think
could you imagine if they gave him that
even if it wasn't a teleprompter
I give him a two percent chance of
getting that one done
and then they hit me with impeachment
hoax number one impeachment hoax number
two the censorship of the Biden family
corruption story as Russian
disinformation by the FBI remember when
they went up to Facebook the crowd and
they said that the his laptop from hell
they call it the laptop from Hell
somebody named Miranda Devine wrote a
great book and she gives me credit for
that she said I saw that name you use
that name I'm so happy with my names I
love my names but she said laptop from
hell was so good that she used it on a
book and it was an incredible book
action and she's a fantastic reporter
but it was the laptop from hell
and they said it was Russia
disinformation no it wasn't it was from
Hunter
can you imagine the father I'm not sure
he understood it but assuming he
understood what was on that laptop now
could you imagine
Don if that ever happens to you if you
ever have a laptop
like that
I will never I swear I'll never speak to
you again
okay that's gonna elicit nervous
laughter from Don Jr who already is sort
of like does my dad even really like me
no could you imagine
assuming he knew what the hell he was
doing could you imagine when he sees oh
my have you seen what's in the really
what's in that the fake news all those
beautiful people look at him they're
waiting for something look at them but
that's a lot wow
but could you imagine though if we had
an honest press where they would
actually report what's on that laptop
that laptop is a disaster and he left it
with the repairman and the repairman is
waiting trying to figure that he opens
it up one day and he says oh my God this
is unbelievable and it was just minor
stuff is reported but that thing is a
disaster and they get left alone
but everyone knew that the Russia
disinformation wasn't true and it made a
17 point difference in the polls but we
didn't need it we had plenty of votes we
had more votes than any president any
sitting president ever more votes by far
but sadly eight million fewer than Biden
all we needed was honest vote counters
Uncle Sam
you know the vote counter is more
important than the candidate I hate to I
could take a great candidate like JD
Vance and I could K take a great
vote counter sorry some democratic
radical left crazy man and I'll bet on
that guy every time I hate to say you
got to be careful we gotta we have to
strengthen up and we have to go to all
paper ballots very quickly right
same day voting all paper ballots Trump
votes by mail
you know in Pennsylvania they just
announced here we go again that it could
take three or four days to come up with
a vote so we're going to be watching
this election
for maybe weeks
and the purpose of these machines was
one of them three or four days is not
exactly weeks France 36 million people
it was all done by 10 o'clock in the
evening and nobody was complaining
I mean you had one person that was sad
and one person that was happy but there
were no complaints and he had all paper
all paper ballots all same-day voting
this stuff with 48 days to vote and then
they take boxes of ballots and they put
them here and they take a wheelbarrow
fully put it there you got some nobody
knows what's going on why are they
moving all those ballots why are they
going
this is the most corrupt system and
that's why we have to have not a bill
Barr that's afraid to act you need
people that are really tough and really
smart right and that love our country
and don't care they love our country you
got to solve this problem but one way
you can help is by just swamping them
with good votes and that's what we have
to do JD we have to get out there and
swap them with the votes because that
gets harder the more you get the hotter
it is you know it's sort of a simple
formula
and then it was the January 6 unselect
committee I love that term I never got
credit for that term you know they go
over it like it's nothing they show the
you know I say that term I give it to
it's very dumb that's why nobody talks
about it and ever correct me they say
this guy's impossible but I love the
term I think it's one of the best the
unselect committee of political hacks
and Thugs and
they have just appalling misconduct on
that committee and the two things they
won't discuss on that committee are the
fact that Nancy Pelosi is in charge of
Capital Security and we recommend it
from 10 to 20 000 soldiers there is no
evidence Trump ever made such a
recommendation or request it is another
one of the lies there is no such
evidence
all I did was make a speech right
peacefully and patriotically
I said peacefully and patriotically and
they say oh that's so terrible you
haven't here Maxine Waters speeches you
ever hear some of these you ever hear
Schumer's speech in front of the Supreme
Court that he should have been in
trouble for that speech and I've told
our attorney general you should look at
that if a mobster made that speech they
would have been put in jail for 10 years
for what humor said in front of the
courthouse and he knows it's right I
pressed it very hard I said what he said
is terrible but the appalling misconduct
is taking place now by the racist
incompetent New York State Attorney
General Leticia peekaboo James
she's terrible who is presiding over
record numbers of murders rapes drug
deals and every other form of crime
she's horrible she doesn't give a damn
about New York remember that the crime
rate for violent crime and property
crime is higher in Oklahoma City than it
is in New York City well opponents
that's all she cares about she wants to
go after political opponents she ran for
governor she got so little vote she she
ran for five weeks and she got out she
had she didn't even register in the
polls
but she said I'm going back to the
attorney general position you know she
left the Attorney General position to
run for governor she failed and then she
went back just last week at her request
a radical left lunatic judge named
ingoren Democrat big big radical left
Democrat uh truly hates me an arrogant
out of control trump-hating maniac
who is totally dominated by my worst
enemies in the Democrat Party this is a
judge that's dominated he's a guy that's
going to make a decision notice that
Newsmax isn't even covering this live
and my family
and hates Trump beyond anything you I
don't know I'm never met him
but he actually said in court that quote
he's just a bad guy Trump he's a bad guy
I never met the gentleman I know nothing
about him I created thousands and
thousands of jobs built an unbelievable
country the the the company that I built
is UN that was unbelievable very little
debt unbelievable assets
great everything it's great and I got
this is really resonating with the dead
silent audience some of whom are already
starting to leave
I said I want jury no no no this guy's
supposed it's a corrupt system New York
is a very corrupt judicial system and
they better get it straightened out
because businesses are leaving New York
right because of things like this but
they started a process of
unconstitutional property confiscation
very much akin to Venezuela Cuba or the
old Soviet Union this case was supposed
to be in front of another judge with
experience but New York state court
system doesn't do that because uh it's
corrupt it's a corrupt system it really
is you have a much better system in Ohio
I don't know who the hell's in charge of
it but they've done a much better job
but they should take this anger and off
the case and put somebody that can be
fair you can't have impartial you can't
have you can't have judges that are
totally partial they have you know they
have their hatreds this is a Trumpeter
you can't do that so I'm being judged by
this political never Trumper
and I'm not even allowed think of it I'm
not allowed to have a jury this is the
beginning of Communism likewise a local
left-wing D.A in Atlanta here's what
should be the soundtrack to This see if
anybody can understand the connection
Integrity even while Atlanta has among
the highest murder rates per capita of
any city in the country and they
actually are higher than per capita
worse than Chicago which is a disaster
and all of these local democrat-run
cases are being directed by Washington
D.C it's part of the Witch Hunt they've
gone on the largest Witch Hunt in
history I have gone through the largest
Witch Hunt in the history of our country
and it's a disgrace and you know a
friend of mine very smart guy came up to
me said you've been going through this
for six and a half years you have to be
the most honest person it's true can you
imagine 11 million pages of documents
they've examined like when Trump said
they spied on my campaign and they
hadn't spied on him
that is like really honest you know that
they're torturing torturing think of
this about a company-owned car didn't
pay tax on a company own car didn't pay
tax on a company on Department they're
called fringe benefits uh didn't report
you got to pay taxes on them it the
education for his grandchildren a very
good man 75 years old they're torturing
him because they want him to say
anything bad about Trump say something
bad they put them in handcuffs a friend
of mine owns a big accounting firm he
said there's never been a case like this
before they have persecuted this man in
order for him to say something and then
ultimately they are from a deal you go
to jail for a couple of weeks or a
couple of months or you go to jail for
many years
he said I have to say this is what think
of what they did anybody out here would
probably take a deal like that I
wouldn't I'll be honest I wouldn't right
but they torture and this is what they
used to do and do currently in communist
countries and that's where we're going
that's where we're going to think of it
handcuffs walked in front a man that
never heard of jail before right a man
that never had a problem with anything
before handcuffs and they perk walked
him in front of the press in handcuffs
and nobody has ever been criminally
charged in this country from what we
understand on a fringe benefit case a
company-owned car think of that didn't
pay tax on a company on car company
owned department and they say that very
few people do
how many people I wonder how many people
here have a company-owned car anybody
have a company do you pay taxes you know
what cover your face please you pay tax
Uncle Sam do you have a company on car
this is crazy I guarantee even Uncle Sam
probably doesn't pay tax you know this
is one of the things the IRS is supposed
to actually watch out for which is all
these benefits that people get are you
paying taxes on it's like it's Trump's
like almost encouraging tax fraud here
Mar-A-Lago in the document hoax case
totally violating my fourth amendment
rights and no president has ever been
treated this way Clinton you know the
sock case he had things in his socks his
socks something happened to him except a
great verdict he's got a great verdict
we go by that verdict the Sox verdict
but no he had it in his socks you know
that right and others took many many
documents they'd take them out of the
White House they took documents I'm the
only one that can't take anything
but maybe our country would be better
off if I actually had the nuclear codes
JD because our enemies would be afraid
unlike the way they are now if I had the
nuclear codes right
Bill Clinton don't forget he lost the
nuclear codes twice
how do you explain that to the military
I've lost the military codes what do you
he lost the military codes twice I
didn't
they're coming after me because I'm
fighting for you that's all it is
and if I wasn't leading in all these
polls I don't know if you find those
poll numbers you could put them up if
you find them back there you Geniuses
that kind of stuff put them up let me
know when they're up we'll talk about
them but we have poll numbers that are
through the roof and so do Republicans
this is going to be a wave I think this
is going to be a very big wave I hope so
starting right here
let's see the radical left thinks by
doing all these Wicked and venomous
things they are making us weaker but
actually they are making us much much
stronger and more unified that's why I'm
starting to think he maybe is not going
to announce tonight the way this is
going very poorly oh there they are look
look Paul numbers okay first one
support 86 that's good but look at the
strong support that's for Trump strong
support
64. right my eyes are okay this is
pathetic not great but they're okay
somewhat so so look at those numbers
okay next slide go ahead next guys are
amazing I didn't even know we'd be doing
this look
look now there's the uh
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
what is happening right now
does anybody knows Trump 71
Ron DeSantis 10. that's okay
Mike Pence
seven
it has to be an incorrect pole you know
why there's no way Cheney gets four
percent I I don't I don't believe
what a stiff what is stiff
Wyoming did a great job they got her out
the biggest defeat in the history of a
congress person nobody's ever lost by 40
nobody's ever lost my 40 she did so
there were no good people up there
they're all good people Tim Scott is a
great person there are a lot of good
people okay what's the next one let's go
do this fast you all having a good time
is there any time better than a trump
rally isn't this time please huh
I'm sure you sell a lot of you everybody
need a mercy band just ask the
moderators we can give Mercy bands if
you can't take it I'll show that but
they never showed these crowds
because they're fake and they're
dishonest and they are truly the enemy
of the people I hate to say it and they
shouldn't be so that's the Ohio did you
ever hear of a state called Ohio
Remember When
remember when Biden came here and he
said it's great to be with the people of
Michigan that did not play well remember
and when he went to Iowa and he said
that he's in Idaho
right he said I love the potatoes and
they're saying we don't do the potato
thinking
oh what we go through no go back to that
one because I love it because it's Ohio
what did it say there let's say Ohio
general election Trump 55 Biden 35 so it
hasn't changed too much since the
election has just gotten better so
that's plus 20. are you hearing this
fake news media you fake inside of it
this is getting even weirder than I
expected go to the next one
Nevada imagine a world in which Trump
beats Biden by 20 in Ohio the way I look
at your friends over there you see that
lexalt is up plus five Lombardo up
against the governor sister lack a real
Beauty he is up five that's great Trump
up 12. let's go to the next one he's a
great polls they just came out general
election
Trump plus 11 on Joe Biden that's a lot
that's a lot
that's North Carolina
[Applause]
they're saying there's no way it's only
11.
I don't think so I I agree and by the
way you know who's here from North
Carolina pretty riveting stuff huh just
an electric speaker
Laura stand up
[Applause]
Laura Trump
Lara he's so popular
Ted bud is doing great but he said if
she ever runs I'm out of this race okay
Ted Budd is doing great Laura you just
made 20 new friends okay
and let's see so that was North Carolina
go ahead next we're way up what's next
uh isn't that nice look at that one
pretty boring route 13. wow
you know what that is don't you you know
what state that is look at that plus 13.
nobody wants to see that look at that
Kansas great place plus 13. you know
what's really funny Trump won Kansas by
15 in 2020. he's putting up a poll as if
it's great news that shows him with a
smaller lead than that which he won by
in Kansas
you think Trump has any idea that's even
the case guy running for the Senate
there too right
a good guy Eric Schmidt
Eric Schmidt is doing well next
Oklahoma plus 29 I love Oklahoma wow
Trump 59 Biden 30
and you know you almost wonder who the
hell are the 30 percent who are they
nothing good is happening in our country
and then Trump's bragging that he's up
29 in Oklahoma
he won it by 33 in 2020.
Trump is polling worse in most of these
states than the results in 2020.
election when you have defund the police
no voter ID high taxes open borders bad
military no money unspent on military
you know I mean how do you win elections
of this stuff
no more oil High Energy prices the only
way you the only way is you cheat okay
you know they want no voter ID they
don't want any country ID in other words
if you are from another country you
don't have to prove anything you just go
in and have fun vote because that's how
they win the election that's the only
way they win because their policy is so
bad they shouldn't even be in the
elections okay
to every citizen who's appalled by the
radical left's lawlessness and
Corruption this election is your chance
to make your voice heard this is a big
deal this is a big election and uh early
voting which is a little concerning
because when you see early voting I say
to everybody vote on Election Day
because it's harder for them to cheat
you know it's much harder because they
don't know how many votes they have to
produce they don't know how many ballots
they have to print out
you know you keep them in suspense and
then you say nope we beat you here
with your vote you can reject left-wing
tyranny and proudly declare the Americas
must remain America must remain a free
country it's got to remain a free this
is not a free country you could take the
five worst Presidents in American
history and put them together and they
would have not done the damage that Joe
Biden has done to our nation in less
than two short years take a look at the
screen
how would you say your mental focus is
[Music]
what's focused
I said I think it's I you know Trump
playing a video of Biden's glitches is
not very smart that's for sure anyway
what Donald Trump yeah Donald Trump I
love Donald Trump but no
Draka
had no more drop boxes Dickinson hologic
and cephe
cephahide that was about a guy named a
rhino named Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real
Beauty had to give the American people
their voice back by building something
called truth truth essential he voted
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama oh God you know we've endorsed Dr
Oz we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
suchin tendulker duviron Colleen as the
great religious teacher Swami Vive come
on
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
United States thank you very much he was
awarded the broad star and the combat
infantry and badge for his service we
have to keep our country gate prepared
but it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore right if you care
about Law and Order look Law and Order
in normal times roughly 40 percent of
fresh vegetables at about 40 percent
China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they deliver
they swept and swept in you know that
sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's ever seen
anything happen units of plasma for
plasma donate plasma into failing New
York Times by
Anonymous really an anonymous
gutless coward I may ask Marilyn
Lockheed
the leading
woman's business a teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while they're parent of himself
no
nobody has to have parental consent and
we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements uh on Jewish
there you go all right so anyway this is
the last guy who should be talking about
glitches your industry going better than
it ever was before by contrast the
radical democrat congress passed one of
the largest tax hikes in American
history unbelievable tax hike horrible
tax hike
really going to be bad for our country
under the Trump Administration we had
the greatest economy in the history of
the world with no inflation
Biden and the democrat congress created
the worst inflation at 50 years 9.1
percent but you know it's much higher
than that it's not 9.1 it's I bet you
it's doubled than that probably more
inflation's 20. I rebuilt our military
including our nuclear capability and the
creation of space force first time in
70. the audio is collapsing space for us
and you know you have a lot of space
force workers right here in Ohio
a lot of a lot of work is done on space
force in Ohio
they surrendered our strength and turned
Afghanistan into the greatest
humiliation our country has ever had I
believe it was the most humiliating
thing that's ever happened to our
country no when Trump won it was Russian
Ukraine with potentially hundreds of
thousands of people dying that would
never have happened
If I Was President would never have
happened
even the other side admits that would
not have happened
the election was rigged and stolen and
now our country is being destroyed
I ran twice I won twice and I did much
better the second time than I did the
first
huh
getting millions and millions more votes
in 2020 than I got in 2016.
and likewise getting more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our
country
meaningless when you lose by 8 million
the first step to saving America is
winning an epic victory for Republicans
tomorrow I don't have to say dates
anymore I don't have to say it's going
to be in three weeks and two days JD all
that work
tomorrow you're going to be so happy I
believe you're going to be happy
I believe it
gonna be your next senator from this
great state of Ohio JD Vance we love you
JD I've gotten to know him really well
he's a Greek he didn't used to like me
too much two three years ago
but he likes me now and I like him and I
don't think it changes I have some of
them
and uh sometimes I won't let him back in
but I met with him and I'll tell you
what he gets it he's smart he's tough
and he was right about a lot of things a
lot of things JD will fight for Ohio
with every bone in his body as a native
of your state who has personally
witnessed the pillaging of Ohio jobs and
the devastation of Ohio communities JD
knows how important it is to have
leaders who put America First and put
Ohio first he wants to put America first
they think that's such a bad thing so
bad
he's a former Marine and a Yale educated
lawyer is a great student
I spoke to somebody that went to Yale
with him he said he was a great student
so I might as well tell you that some
people said oh don't put it out that
she's Elite well yeah he's Elite he's
Elite in intelligence and that's what we
want right
and he'll bring the toughness and
intellectual Firepower we need to
Champion our movement and our values in
the U.S Senate he will fight for strong
borders fair trade more Ohio jobs and he
will be tough as you can be on crime JD
will never be owned by The Establishment
and he won't be owned by me either
unfortunately I'd love to own the guy
but I don't think he'll be there for me
but that's okay
you know what I'm doing the right thing
for the country he's a very independent
guy
and he'll be an independent senator who
is loyal only to the people of Ohio
that's what he loves the people of Ohio
he loves the state
when JD wins tomorrow night you are
going to hear the Wailing and shrieking
of the fake news all the way from New
York to Washington because the media
will know that Ohio has just elected a
truly Maga All-Star make America great
again
he's an All-Star go figure and he has
been for a long time we're actually
saying the same thing but we're saying
it differently don't you think you know
when I really look back we're saying the
exact same thing just a little bit
differently JD is running against a
do-nothing showboating radical Democrat
politician named Tim Ryan the truth is
Tim Ryan is very Centrist there's
nothing radical about Tim Ryan at all oh
did I hit China hard we took in 430
billion dollars from China not one other
president took in 10 cents
Ryan pretends to be a moderate pretends
to be almost a trump supporter I wish
voted with crazy Nancy Pelosi 100 of the
time over the last two years 100 percent
and then he tries to say that he's with
me he's not with me
he supported Joe Biden's war on American
Energy he voted for a massive tax
increase on Ohio Workers and families
and he voted for Mass amnesty and free
government health care for illegal
aliens he wanted them to come in he
wants the open borders let them all come
in from all over the world
even if they come from the prisons of
these other places that are very tough
places Tim Ryan declared that he is all
for releasing criminals from prison and
emptying out American jails and he
supports abolishing cash bail that's the
real Tim Ryan by the way that's not
the Trump Ally
Tim Ryan has also voted repeatedly to
continue Democrats war on Ohio energy
workers he wants to stop energy and you
make a fortune with energy and a fortune
in jobs your taxes would double and
triple if you ever did that it would not
he voted to cancel the Keystone XL
pipeline how about that one I started it
immediately my first day in office and
they ended it as soon as they got there
he said their plan to eliminate
coal-fired power plants was amazing he
just loved it he used the word amazing
and he said that he wants to get rid of
all gas vehicles which would decimate
the Ohio Auto industry all electric
wonderful great for China not good for
us great for China
but just 24 hours from now Tim Ryan is
going to be out of a job J.D Vance is
going to be on his way to the United
States Senate and JD is a really good
man JD please come up here we go he'd
better suck up
you've got to suck up otherwise you're
screwed
so just so people know I'm getting
reports that over on Fox
uh the Chiron at the bottom has said
stuff like tremix Trump expected to make
a big announcement and stuff like that
so we're we're watching it all very very
closely here take it out there and run
up the score on these guys because we
need to win and we need to win big and
take our country back that's exactly
what we're gonna do the simple the
simple thing here is we need Senators
who are Fighters and Senators who are
doers no more talking about big Tech no
more talking about the Border we need to
people who are going to fight for the
issues and actually get something done
for the people of Ohio that's what I
want to do let's get out to the polls
tomorrow thank you all
thank you gold
thank you JD you're gonna win big I'm
going to send a signal to these people
that are ruining our country they're
destroying our country
tomorrow you also need together we'll be
we learned nothing from 2016 and we're
still voting for morons
John you said you got to do that he's
done a good job
[Applause]
he's done a good job
Mike and John have been an outstanding
team who have fought tirelessly to bring
jobs and factories back to Ohio I worked
with them and doing that including the
20 billion dollar Intel plant that will
create more than 20 000 Ohio jobs and
they cut taxes slash regulations and
they delivered historic funding for
support and for the police officers and
they've really done a job Mike and John
are running against a radical left
lunatic it was a disaster is the mayor
of Dayton I got to know her when we had
a terrible shooting here remember I went
to the hospital I got to know her and I
said that's she's not good
Nan Whaley
well it's not much of a race I have to
tell you they're so far ahead but no but
I got to know her she was terrible yeah
under her watch
Dayton Ohio Dayton had one of the
highest murder rates in the entire
country yet she backed a budget to
cancel the police academy as a
commissioner she voted to defund the
police so that's wonderful that's what
we need in Dayton with crime is setting
records let's defund the police right
she's a high tax High regulation far
left liberal who would demolish your
economy in a matter of months I think it
would be very quick and she would
totally betray the values of the people
of Ohio who have the finest values you
can have Ohio needs to get up and just
vote for these two great people Mike
dewine and John Houston
uh-huh
by the way are they here right thanks
come on up
well this is a great honor
and I gave my endorsement this one's
kind of dragging uh very very slow
moving that's really nice hi Jack
great
oh Trump now is covering it let's uh I'm
sorry Newsmax let's switch over to the
actually wait you know what let's not
it's like 20 minutes behind again
Mr President thank you very much oh God
you know in Ohio Mr President we fund
the police we've done a great job doing
that we've cut our taxes we're moving
Ohio forward and thank you for being
here to endorse JD Vance JD is going to
do an absolute phenomenal job
[Applause]
thank you
did you want to say something the guy
said no well that was a very nice
welcome but he's up by 25 points or
something and they should be they should
be
thank you
thank you very much fellas
thank you very much in addition to
reelecting Mike and John we need
everyone to get out and vote for
the Republican candidates for Ohio
Supreme Court Sharon Kennedy Pat Fisher
Pat dewine
and we're also joined tonight by Ohio
Secretary of State Frank Larose where's
Frank that's important hi Frank
nice looking young guy Frank you're
doing a great job really great job
State Treasurer Robert Sprague Robert
thank you very much great job
state auditor Keith Faber thank you kid
a man uh that I love I tell you I'm not
I'm not a big lover of men
but this guy I love
um you know he was one of the best
wrestlers in the country his sons are
both
his sons are both all Americans and I
spoke to his one boys actually a larger
person than him I think like a 188 or
something
and he's All-American I said well would
you say you were better than your father
he said sir I wasn't even close and he
meant it too sure but he is a fighter
just like he was as a great wrestler
virtually undefeated and he was the NCAA
champion champion of the country
you know I I dealt with them for a long
time and I'd look at that face
and I said you know those ears are a
little little move there's a little
action going on with those ears I see
people in the chat asking why he's
angled to the side this is a
teleprompter he's just reading he's
angled towards this teleprompter that's
what he's doing that's why he's angled
that way in the in the in the whole
country best wrestler
and but I looked at it and I looked at
those ears I shouldn't say this because
they've never told us I said that guy
had some things going on with the
fighting stuff
but he is such a warrior and such an
incredible guy is he here is he here
well come here come here I love this guy
come here who's even calling up
oh it's Jim Jordan Mr President but uh
they want you back here I'll just say
this my my favorite scripture verse is
second Timothy 4 7. that's Trump's face
fight the good fight finish the course
keep the faith and I and I tell folks
I tell folks that's a verse for our
country right fight finish keep words of
action not timid words not [ __ ] words
words that we associate with America and
words that we associate with the best
president we've ever had president Trump
God bless you all
what a thinker that Jim Jordan huh very
smart guy thank you Jim very much
Tim and a friend of Jim's and a friend
of all of us Warren Davidson Warren
thank you very much good job you doing
Mike Carey and a person who Mike where's
Mike hi Mike great good job Mike Warrior
another Warrior a person who's very shy
very timid we're trying to get her to
get a little tough the audio was just
really degenerating
[Music]
[Applause]
she did a commercial yes yes yes
somebody can break into my house we'll
treat it very nicely but first he's got
to go through this and she takes I said
that's a hell of a commercial
but she's great and she's done a
tremendous job and she's highly
respected highly respected and she just
won with almost like everybody voted for
her she's great thank you very much
Marjorie it's an honor to have you
congressional candidates oh I love this
guy Max Miller where's Max
so where is Max
I'll tell you you the job he's done yep
right and he was with me for four years
I know him maybe almost as well as that
guy right there Jim but Max is going to
be a great congressman and uh he turned
out to be an incredible campaigner you
know they're having a hard time with the
district and it kept getting worse and
worse Academy was a trump plus 20 then
it was a trump plus 10 then it was a
trump plus two they kept playing
and he kept saying don't worry about it
sir I'm going to win anyway doesn't
matter and then it went the other way
was a little Democrat he said don't
worry about it and then in the end it
became like a trump plus 18. I don't
know how the hell you pull that off but
you know what you did a great job for me
Max and I'm here for you and you're
going to have a great career so right
young man and a great man grew up right
right here
thank you very much Max and J.R Majewski
you know he suffered a lot of false
false statements
and I just want to tell you everyone
knows they they are all of the people
that I've just named but they have my
complete and total endorsement you know
that and uh they treated Jr very
unfairly they made up a lot of stories
he's a tremendous Warrior and a great
gentleman and I think he's going to do
very well tomorrow but I think you got
treated very unfairly I don't even know
what's going to happen you know the fake
news went after him and uh we don't know
what's going to happen but I think
you're going to have a good result
people know that you are a legitimate
hero you don't told me that he lied you
know I told him that Jim Jordan that's
all I have to to here when Jim says it
so good luck tomorrow fellas good luck
tomorrow Ohio Republican party chairman
a friend of mine Bob paduczek
Bob
great you're doing great Bob the party's
doing great and a man that's the
greatest buyer of commercials in the
history of our country Michael
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
he's the greatest in history
at buying commercials
and he's a patriot too you know the FBI
raided him they took his phone I don't
know what the hell they're going to
learn about pillows I don't know why
they want
they'll know everything they used to
know about pillows thank you Mike
when Republicans take back Congress this
week we will fight for the people of
Ohio and we will win for the people of
Ohio one of the first things we must do
is stand up for can you believe this
parental rights who ever thought here we
go hey can you believe I think I'm
called a politic I hate to call myself a
politician but a politician would have
to stick up for parental rights the
parents have their rights but now we
have to fight because the radical left
lunatics want to take parents rights
away from them but we won't let that
happen we will get critical race Theory
out of our schools out of our military
and out of every part of our federal
state
and local governments and at long last
every parent in America must be
empowered to opt out of the forced
indoctrination in the classroom and send
their child to the public private
Charter religious or home school of
their choice we will also if you don't
mind it's Politically Incorrect they
tell me but I'm okay with it we will
keep men
like Jim Jordan out of women's sports
okay
I want to find a woman
that can beat him I'd pay a lot to watch
it
I'd pay a lot of money to watch that no
teacher should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to our children without
parental
consent I mean can you imagine they
actually do it without parental consent
the country's going crazy
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican Congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in America
Free Speech has gotten so free it'll
cost you eight bucks on Twitter it's
better than Twitter it's better than all
of them just go out and get it it's hot
as a pistol and everywhere the
Republican party has the chance we must
pass critical rate we have to do this
that's a glitch election Integrity
reforms including Universal voter ID
citizenship confirmation you know
they're fighting us on citizenship
confirmation can you believe it now
the only reason somebody wouldn't want
to do that think of it is they have to
cheat okay common thing who wouldn't
want that we don't want to learn where
you come from what country do you come
from you're not allowed to ask a
question like that as they go to vote
for your local representative no more
fake drop boxes JD no private money
pouring into local election offices and
ultimately we need same-day voting with
only paper ballots and voter ID
and you save a lot of money on the
machines you're going to save a lot of
money on them you see
now think of it Pennsylvania three four
days they're going to be three four days
late what a joke what a joke there's
something going on
we're just hours away from the most
important midterm election in American
history and we need a landslide so big
that the radical left cannot rig it or
cannot steal it everybody needs to get
out and vote and if you care about
election Integrity volunteer as an
election worker a poll Watcher a poll
Challenger that's what you have to do
because they do it and they do it in a
very rough manner but we're going to
swamp them this is the year we're going
to take back the house we're going to
take back the Senate and we're going to
take back America and in 2024 most
importantly we are going to take back
our magnificent White House
okay
is he gonna do it take it back
[Applause]
[Music]
together we will fight I guess not for
more jobs for Ohio families fair trade
for Ohio Workers and more Ohio factories
forging more products stamped with Uncle
Sam the beautiful phrase made in the USA
Uncle Sam
we will shut down Biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in Mexico policy strengthen the Patriots
and they are indeed Patriots of ice and
Border Patrol and we will again end
Catch and Release we will end chain
migration we will end the Visa Lottery
and we will end illegal immigration in
our country once and for all we want
people to come in but they have to come
in legally have to come in Legally
we will stop the crime wave and
democrat-run cities we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect that they deserve and we will
not take legal protection away from our
police they want to take protection so
that if somebody sues a police person
for doing their job they have to go out
and hire their own lawyer that's not a
good idea we will restore law in order
in America we will hold China
accountable for unleashing the virus
upon the world 65 trillion dollars in
damage they can't pay that much but
something's going to happen we will
abolish all coveted mandates
and rehire every Patriot who was fired
from the military with an apology and
full back pay not gonna happen
I bet you anything that that does not
happen
and we will defend our constitution we
will defend the Second Amendment and we
will proudly uphold the judeo-christian
values and principles of our nation's
founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American flag always respect our flag
in conclusion
our Maga movement make America great
again is by far the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
is it now
they never challenge that they've never
challenged this amazing thing they
wouldn't challenge it if I said anything
slightly wrong they challenge but they
can challenge that together we are
standing up against some of the most
menacing forces entrenched interests and
vicious opponents our people have ever
seen despite great outside dangers our
biggest threat Remains the sick Sinister
and evil people
from within our country you know who I'm
talking about you see them all the time
but no matter how big or powerful the
corrupt radical left Democrats that we
are fighting against may be you must
never forget this nation does not belong
to them this nation belongs to you
that's who it belongs to
this is your home
this is your heritage and our American
Liberty is your God given right
from Akron to Toledo from Cleveland to
Columbus from Youngstown to Dayton you
inherit the legacy of generations of
Americans who risk their everything
for the Beloved Country that they love
so much Ohio is the state that gave us
American Heroes icons and legends with
names like Neil Armstrong Annie Oakley
and the great General and President
Ulysses S Grant Ulysses and this is the
state that gave us Legions we literally
had that on our glitch compilation
Ulysses and who built this country with
the sweat of their brows and the
strength
of their spines what about Billy the
could
but they also give us something very
very special the goodness of their souls
your Ohio ancestors fought the battles
they broke the barriers they conquered
the unknown dangers they pushed into
unchartered Frontiers and they made
America into the greatest nation in the
history
of the world
here it is
[Music]
here it is
[Music]
but now
we are a nation in Decline
we are a failing Nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in 50 years and where the
stock market finished the worst first
half of the year since 1872
likewise we are here's my version of it
okay
look having nuclear my uncle was a great
professor and scientist and engineer Dr
John Trump at MIT
good genes very good genes okay very
smart
Wharton School of Finance very good very
smart
you know if you're a Conservative
Republican if I were a liberal like if
like okay I ran as a liberal Democrat
they would say I'm one of the smartest
people anywhere in the world it's true
but when you're a Conservative
Republican they try oh they do a number
that's why start off went to Wharton
was a good student
built a fortune you know I have to give
my credentials all the time
anyway Dr John Trump even though they
can't go far costs too much and whose
batteries are produced in China with
materials only available in China when
an unlimited amount of gasoline is
available inexpensively
in the United States but it is not
available in China
we are a nation that ended oil
exploration and production in the United
States just as the price of oil reached
an all-time high we did not end
production in the United States
we are a nation that surrendered in
Afghanistan leaving behind dead soldiers
American citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
anywhere in the world
we are a nation that allowed Russia to
devastate a country Ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people
and it will only get worse it would
never have happened with me as your
commander-in-chief and for four straight
years it didn't happen and China with
Taiwan is next we are a nation that has
weaponized its law enforcement against
opposing political parties
like never before
we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation
that won't allow bad election-changing
facts to be presented to the public and
which offers one million dollars to a
writer of fiction about Donald Trump to
lie
and say it was fact and pays a man two
hundred thousand dollars to get Trump go
out and get Trump
where Hunter Biden's laptop from hell
was Russian disinformation and the FBI
knew it wasn't and a department of
justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we have a man who is the worst
president in the history of our country
who is cognitively impaired in no
condition to lead
and is now casually talking about
nuclear war with Russia which would be
World War III and far more devastating
than any of the previous world wars sure
because of the Weaponry that no one can
ever even imagine or think about it is
so powerful we are a nation that no
longer has a free press fake news is all
you get
and they are indeed the enemy of the
people we are a nation where free speech
is no longer allowed where crime is
rampant and out of control they've
banned free speech and where more people
died of covet in 2021 than in 2020 we
are a nation that is allowing Iran to
build a massive nuclear weapon and China
to use the trillions and trillions of
dollars that has taken from us to build
a military to rival our own
and just two years ago we had Iran China
Russia and North Korea in check
they weren't going to do a thing against
us
and everyone knows it they respected us
more than they ever respected us sounds
pretty bad perhaps most importantly
We're a nation
that no longer is respected or listened
to anywhere around the world we are a
nation
that in many ways has become a joke we
are a nation that is hostile to Liberty
freedom and Faith oh the mic pillow ad
is perfectly timed collapsing into a
cesspool of Ruin whose supply chain is
broken the stores are not stocked whose
deliveries are not coming and whose
educational system is ranked at the very
bottom of every single list
we are a nation where large packs of
sadistic criminals and thieves are
allowed to go into stores and openly Rob
them beat up the workers and kill the
customers leave with offloads of goods
but with no retribution we're the
authority of our great police has been
taken where their families and pensions
have been threatened and their lives
would be destroyed for the mere mention
of the words law enforcement
we are a nation where the people are
allowed to murder kill Rob and rape
innocent victims and they have no cash
ban and they're back on the streets
allowed to do it again in a matter of
hours right we are a nation where
Fentanyl and all other forms of illegal
drugs are easier to get than formula for
our beautiful little babies a nation
whose once revered airports are dirty
crowded a mess and unsightly horrible
mess you sit and wait for hours and then
are notified that the plane won't leave
and they have no idea when it will where
ticket prices have tripled they don't
have the pilots to fly the planes they
don't see qualified air traffic
controllers and they just don't know
what the hell they're doing we are some
flights they don't even allow peanuts
power and its strength and we are a
nation that has just plain lost its way
but we are a nation
that is not going to allow this horror
to continue two years ago we were a
great nation and we will be a great
nation again
[Applause]
[Music]
but not to detract from tomorrow's very
important even critical
election uh oh
and I would say in the strongest way
it's a country-saving election
specifically including
the election of all the people that I'm
going to name
I'm going to be making
a very big announcement on Tuesday
November 15th oh at Mar-A-Lago in Palm
Beach Florida oh boy
oh boy
we want nothing to detract from the
importance of Tomorrow you understand
that JD right
so I'm going to go over a list of people
and I think you'll find it very in
really inspired I know when Trump does
lists it's so bad
so we must first elect
JD Vance for the senate in Ohio
Mike dewine for governor in Ohio
Dr Oz for Senate in Pennsylvania
Doug mastriano for governor in
Pennsylvania
he's going to lose Blake Masters for
Senate in Arizona he may win Terry Lake
for governor in Arizona sadly she may
win
great guy who I've known for a long time
he fought with Jim Jordan and all the
rest on the fake impeachments
Lee zeldon for governor in New York he's
doing great
one of the greatest athletes you'll ever
meet Herschel Walker for Senate in
Georgia
and Brian Kemp for governor in Georgia
[Music]
Adam black salt for Senate in Nevada
and Joe Lombardo for governor this I can
tell you Trump is not going to be 100 in
his endorsements tomorrow
that's for sure the sentence for
governor in Florida
Tudor Dixon for governor in Michigan
[Music]
and Ron Johnson for Senate in Wisconsin
Tim Michaels for governor in Wisconsin
Chuck Grassley for Senate in Iowa
and Kim Reynolds for governor in Iowa
Katie Brent for Senate in Alabama
Kelly isn't this insane Senate in Alaska
Mike Dunleavy for governor in Alaska
John Bozeman for Senate in Arkansas
Sarah Sanders did you ever hear of her
great for governor in Arkansas
Leora Levy for Senate in Connecticut
Mike crapo for Senate in Idaho
Jerry Moran for Senate in Kansas
Derek Schmidt for governor in Kansas
Rand Paul for senate in Kentucky
[Applause]
John Kennedy for Senate in Louisiana
[Music]
Eric Schmidt for Senator in Missouri
Ted Bundt for Senate in North Carolina
John Hoven for Senate in North Dakota oh
God James Lankford for Senate in
Oklahoma Langford is scary Mark Mark
Wayne Mullen who's a great guy great
future for Senate in Oklahoma
[Music]
Tim Scott another great great guy for
Senate in South Carolina
Henry McMaster doing an unbelievable job
for governor in South Carolina
Mike Lee for Senate in Utah
[Music]
Gerald Malloy for Senate in Vermont
Darren Bailey he's doing great for
governor in Illinois and Illinois has to
defeat pritzker
Darren's gonna do it Dan Cox for
governor in Maryland
Jeff deal for governor in Massachusetts
Scott Jensen for governor of Minnesota
Mark ronchetti for governor of New
Mexico
Christy gnome for governor of South
Dakota
Billy for governor in Tennessee
this is completely insane like I mean
that's just
all of our wonderful Attorney General
candidates
a Pomade in Arizona Tim Griffin oh my
God Ashley moody in Florida Brenna Byrd
in Iowa Matt diperno in Michigan City
Michael Henry
tendulker Dave Yost in Ohio
[Applause]
and Ken Paxton in Texas
and all other Trump endorsed Republicans
up and down the line including Mark
fincham Jim Marshall Christina caramel
it was hard-working Patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working Patriots like you who are
going to save our country we will stand
up to the radical left Democrats and we
will I'm going to write in Vivek
hmm there is no mountain we cannot climb
there is no Summit we cannot reach there
is no challenge we cannot meet there is
no Victory we cannot have we will not
Bend we will not break we will not yield
we will never give in we will never give
up and we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident United and
loyal to the cause the tyrants we are
fighting do not stand even a chance
because we are Americans and Americans
kneel to God and to God Alone
[Applause]
the silent majority is back and stronger
than ever before we will take our
country back my fellow citizens this
incredible journey we are on together
has only just begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness greatness greatness greatness
again for our country
We Are One movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under God
so with the help of everyone here
tonight and citizens all across our land
we will make America powerful again
[Applause]
we will make America wealthy again sure
we will make America strong again
we will make America proud again
we will make America safe again and we
will make America great again thank you
Ohio thank you God bless you thank you
JD go get em thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Ty depressing event
Donald Trump making it clear
he will be making an announcement next
Tuesday at Mar-A-Lago of course I will
plan to cover it
uh if and when the timing is announced
please let me know
presumably presumably the announcement
that he is running for president I have
to tell you I think to some degree this
pre-announcement if anything can only
hurt Republicans tomorrow
tomorrow is a critical day everybody
should vote everybody should vote if you
start thinking to yourself oh no uh my
vote won't matter my one vote never
makes a difference there are hundreds of
thousands of people sharing that that
sentiment and if all of us stay home we
lose okay if all of us stay home we lose
I am covering elections live tomorrow
please join me tomorrow please join me
tomorrow please join me tomorrow
if you're watching on YouTube hit the
Subscribe button it's free after all
make sure you're following me on Twitch
make sure you've liked on Facebook but
we are trying to pump and pump and pump
the YouTube subscriber numbers
as you head out
hit the Subscribe button we're streaming
daily
we will be here tomorrow okay vote
it may not be as bad as the polls
suggest it really may not
okay we're not throwing in the towel
we're not throwing in the towel
um I believe indeed that yes the polling
May slightly be be a little too generous
towards Republicans okay we'll start
between seven and eight tomorrow I will
set the live stream and everybody can
see it nobody has sung yet forget about
the fat lady has not yet sung nobody has
sung yet
okay so we'll see everybody tomorrow
thank you for joining me let's do the
thing let's make it happen don't troll
don't be a horrible person
don't send me absurd emails all right
see everybody tomorrow